Die Eintracht aus Braunschweig startete furios in die laufende Saison, um nun seit zwei Monaten sieglos zu sein. Woran liegt das? Der KSC hingegen mischt mal wieder ganz oben mit, obwohl sie ihm nicht ganz so viele zugetraut hatten. Was macht Christian Eichner also so gut? Wir wagen einen Blick auf die 2. Liga-Teams, die bislang weniger am Vorkuss standen, auch hier im Rasenfunk, mit Anna Lautenbach und Thomas Haufe. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Profis zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Gili Landkampf. Waakra, Martin Waakra.
Und das Anzündung. Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Alex hat den Schuh!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
So schnell sind zwei Wochen schon wieder vorbei. Herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Herzlich willkommen in der Zweitligaliga-Tour, in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Marc. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese Fußballsendung. Ja, ihr müsst Eva entschuldigen. Ja, Taylor Swift-Wochenende. Die kann einfach nicht. Die kann nicht. Ihr sind die Hände und Ohren gebunden. Ihr müsst mit mir vorliebt nehmen. Und ich stelle mir noch mal vor, Marc Schilzki, mein Name ist freier Journalist. Ihr hört mich hier im Rasenfunk. Ihr hört mich bei HerthaBase. Und wenn ihr mich lest, dann meistens auf rbb24.de. Ich bin heute natürlich nicht alleine. Zum einen ist dabei, sie ist die Frau für die schönen Formulierungen und den hässlichen Fußball-Anhängerin der Braunschweig Eintracht, Mitglied des Gegengerade-Podcasts Anna Lautenbach. Grüß dich.
Hallo, Marc. Ja, das ist leider richtig.
Ich wollte sagen, ich habe mich schon gefragt. Als ich das aufgeschrieben habe, wusste ich nicht, lehne ich mich zu weit drüber?
Nein, nein. Also ich möchte an der Stelle wirklich sagen, ich freue mich einfach wirklich, hier zu sein. Zum einen sowieso über die Einladung, zum anderen hat es ja auch mit einer sportlichen Qualifikation zu tun. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass mein Verein, die im Mai geschafft hat und sie jetzt direkt wieder ansägt.
Es ist heute so ein bisschen die Krisenfolge, muss man so sagen. Es hätte auch anders kommen können. Also die Besetzung stand früher fest als der Spieltag. Eure Vereine hatten es in der Hand, aber es sollte nicht so sein. Der andere krisengeschüttelte Gast ist Thomas Haufe. Passend zum Wochenende der Wiedervereinigung haben wir uns hier die Ostkompetenz rein geholt. Magdeburg-Fan, nur der FCM-Podcaster ist auch dabei. Grüß dich, Thomas.
Ja, hallo. Schöne Grüße in die Runde.
So, bevor wir sportlich werden, natürlich der allgemeine Hinweis. Sprecht es mir nach, der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich über die Spenden der HörerInnen. In dieser Folge beispielsweise genannt Kieler Sprotte. Das passt. Wir reden heute über Holstein Kiel. Alex, Luke, Moulineo, Sternburg, sie unterstützen diesen Podcast finanziell. Und diese finanzieren nicht nur den Lebensunterhalt von Max, sondern machen auch möglich, dass zum Beispiel Eva oder ich auch solche Sendungen moderieren können, der Rasenfunk als ein noch bunterer Fußballblumenstrauß wird. Das ist doch schön. Wenn ihr das auch unterstützen wollt, dann schaut vorbei auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. So, wir werden sportlich und beginnen anders. Ich führe erst mal kurz durch die Sendung. Ihr wisst ja noch gar nicht, was euch heute erwartet. Wir wollen heute, wie gesagt, wie im Intro gesagt, über die Vereine reden, die noch nicht so im Vorkestand der Saison, weil sie noch nicht die ganz großen Geschichten geschrieben haben und die auch im Rasenfunk noch nicht große Beachtung gefunden haben. Es wurde beispielsweise in den Kommentaren ja auch schon die Kieler-Besprechung gefordert. Das machen wir heute. Und vorher möchte ich aber kurz mit euch über die Lage der Liga reden, über das, was am Spieltag vielleicht die größten Kreise gezogen hat. Klar, wir könnten jetzt über Schalke auf Platz zwei und so reden. Aber wie gesagt, diese Vereine haben ja schon ihre Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und werden sie auch weiter bekommen. Stattdessen würde ich sehr gerne darüber reden, dass Düsseldorf und Magdeburg sich womöglich ein Schicksal nach diesem Spieltag teilen, womöglich zum nächsten Spieltag mit einem neuen Trainer dastehen. Darüber reden wir jetzt mal kurz. Anna, hast du dir das Krisenduell zwischen Düsseldorf und Nürnberg angeguckt zufällig?
Ich hatte die Konferenz an, ja.
Das reicht ja.
Ja, genau. Ich habe es durchaus mitbekommen und ja, es ist krass tatsächlich. Also ich finde, da gewinnt der Fußball so ein bisschen an Drama relativ früh in der Saison bei solchen Begegnungen, weil einfach zwei Mannschaften dann doch deutlich an den Erwartungen vorbeispielen. Wobei, weiß ich nicht, wie geht es euch da? Also, dass Nürnberg so crasht, da bin ich jetzt nicht komplett schockiert.
Nee, da rennt sie bei mir offene Türen ein und da halte ich gefühlt auch jetzt schon mal Miroslav Klose-Pledoyer. Denn ich finde, diese Saisonbeginn von Nürnberg ist keine Trainer-Krise, sondern ist dem geschuldet, wie der Transfer-Sommer lief. Man hat nahezu alle Stützen dieses Kaders verloren, mit Janda, Kastrop, Zimas, Emreli, Antis vor allen Dingen, die komplett gefühlte Offensiv-Anteilung, alles, was Tore schießen konnte, ist im Sommer gegangen. Die Transfers, die gekommen sind, waren entweder gefühlte A-Jugendspieler oder Spieler, die noch nie in Deutschland gespielt haben. Und diese Transfers sind sehr oft auch noch sehr spät passiert. So, dass dieser Start also so rucklig sein könnte, ist für mich überhaupt nicht überraschend gewesen. Ich finde, dass Miroslav Klose das sehr ruhig moderiert hat. Und sie haben dieses Spiel jetzt in Düsseldorf, um da überzuleiten, verdient gewonnen, in meinen Augen. Es war ein guter Auswärtsauftritt, kein überragender, aber ein guter, das war gut strukturiert, das war in den wichtigen Momenten effizient, Leute wie Soma scheinen allmählich anzukommen. Und man war einfach das reifere Team in dem Spiel, was eher wusste, wie es dieses Spiel gewinnen könnte. Und deswegen finde ich das richtige Signal auch für den Trainer, weil ich nicht das Gefühl habe, dass es am Microsoft-Close lag. Mir hätte erst mal jemand den Trainer zeigen sollen, der das besser moderiert, das besser hinbekommt, was bei Nürnberg im Sommer passiert ist. Aber wenn wir den Blick quasi auf Düsseldorf werfen, Thomas, das war ja wiederum ein Auftritt, der wirklich Sorgen machen muss, insbesondere mit Bezug auf die letzten Auftritte insgesamt.
Ja, also Düsseldorf ist wirklich schon arg erschreckend. Also letzte Saison konnte man es ja so ein bisschen, finde ich, auch auf die Verletztenvisere schieben, die sie hatten. Es fällt diese Saison ja erst mal noch flach. Klar haben sie natürlich auch wieder, gerade mit Johanneson finde ich, einen sehr, sehr wichtigen Spieler verloren. Aber man muss schon sagen, was da in Düsseldorf gerade abgeht. Also wo das auch herkommt. Du hast das ja im WhatsApp-Roll schon ganz gut beschrieben, finde ich. Vorher war es immer so, dass Tune auf jeden Fall abwehr konnte. Also Düsseldorf war ja immer schwer zu bespielen in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren. Aber auch diese Abwehrschwäche, die die auch haben, das ist ja schon erschreckend. Nach vorne geht dann auch nicht viel. Ja, und dann stehst du da eben, ich glaube, mit 7, 8, 9, 10 Punkten da, so ein bisschen im Niemandsland der Tabelle gerade, wo man schon, glaube ich, in Düsseldorf ganz andere Pläne hatte. Und die Trainer-Diskussion, die da vielleicht jetzt kommt, ist schwierig.
Wird ja auch von den Verantwortlichen nicht aufgehalten. Also Klaus Alos hat ja schon vor ein, zwei Spieltagen klar gesagt, dass man da auch den Trainer mit in die Verantwortung nimmt und diese Trainer-Diskussion auch nicht wegdiskutieren kann. Anscheinend ja auch nicht will. Das muss man ja auch sagen. Man kann das ja unterbinden. Man kann ja dem Trainer das Vertrauen besprechen. Ist so nicht passiert. Wie du sagst, ich hatte es auch in unserer WhatsApp-Gruppe geschrieben. Daniel Tune war immer ein guter Defensiv-Trainer, aber auch jemand, der eben für Ergebnis-Fußball steht, der irgendwie es zumindest offensichtlich schafft, zumindest seinen Individualkünstlern, sage ich mal, die Freiheiten zu geben. Die wirken bislang aber nicht gut. Also Muslia ist dann noch der beste gefühlt. Rasmussen hat gefühlt ein gutes Spiel gemacht und seitdem ist er unsichtbar. Cedric Itten kommt nicht oft genug in die Momente, die er dann definitiv nutzen würde. Und defensiv ist das ein Hühnerhaufen. Also die wurden teilweise von Nürnberg hergespielt. Vor allen Dingen, das Eklatanteste war wirklich dann, also natürlich diese wilde Schlussphase, in der dann einige Tore fallen. Aber wie Düsseldorf das 3 zu 2 kassiert oder 2 zu 3, je nach Perspektive, das hat nichts mit Zweitliga zu tun. Also Nürnberg filetiert die durch die Spielmitte. Düsseldorf kriegt nicht einmal den Zugriff. Vielleicht zeigt sich eben genau da auch, dass du mit Johannesson auch ein Stück weit das Herzstück der Mittelfeldzentrale verloren hast. Ein Jahr davor ja Engelhardt, das war ja besonders da das Team, was echt gut funktioniert hat. Das hat man bislang nicht ersetzt bekommen. Und ich finde das, was Kastenmayer nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, auch interessant, weil der wirkt auch ratlos. Und einerseits wollte er sich irgendwie vor den Trainer stellen, hat aber implizit auch gesagt, dass das nicht mehr passt. Denn wenn er die ganze Zeit sagt, wir reden so viel, wir reden so viel miteinander, und dann darf ich mich alle zwei Wochen hier hinstellen und es sah wieder scheiße aus, dann spricht das ja auch nicht, dass das, was man mit dem Trainer beredet, fruchtet. Und dann erreicht der Trainer diese typische Floskel noch die Mannschaft oder ist dann irgendwann vielleicht auch mal so ein Zyklus aufgebraucht? Man weiß es nicht so genau, aber zumindest stehen die Zeichen da. Auf Abschied habe ich das Gefühl. Wie ist es denn bei Magdeburg, Thomas? Magdeburg hat jetzt, du kommst quasi frisch von der Schocktherapie. Wie gesagt, Magdeburg heute eigentlich kein Schwerpunktthema, aber wo wir dich einmal da haben, müssen wir schon natürlich darüber reden. Jetzt am Sonntag ein saftiges 0 zu 4 im eigenen Stadion gegen Elbersberg kassiert. Tides desolat würde ich jetzt erstmal so in den Raum stellen. Ja. Und dazu kommt natürlich die weite Perspektive. Es ist jetzt die sechste Niederlage in Serie. Man hat sieben aus acht Spielen verloren, ist mit drei Punkten tabellenletzter. Lass mal deinen gefühlenfreien Lauf und beantworte dann am Ende vielleicht die Frage, kann es denn so mit Markus Fiedler weitergehen?
Ja, die Gefühlslage ist natürlich maximal beschissen. Also wenn du jetzt nach vier Spielen folgst, jetzt auch selber keinen Tor machst, ein Ding nach dem anderen verlierst, teilweise auch wirklich, wie du schon sagst, wenn man das Schalke-Spiel nimmt, oder auch heute nach 15 Minuten dann auch nach dem 0-1 vor allem, dann Desolat. Die Spiele laufen irgendwie alle gleich. Du fängst gut an, hast eine gute Anfangsphase, spielst dir Chancen raus, machst eigentlich vieles richtig, bis auf den Abschluss. Hier ist das 0-1 und diese Mannschaft fliegt in sich so dermaßen zusammen. Das ist schon krass. Das Schlimme ist, es hat sich so ein bisschen letzte Saison, zum Ende der letzten Saison auch schon angedeutet, als man dann in diesen wichtigen Spielen, wo es dann darum ging, diese große Überraschung vielleicht zu schaffen, eben auch komplett eingeknickt ist, das 0-1 in Ulm damals, und vor allem auch das 0-5 gegen Münster. Das setzt sich diese Saison komplett fort. Ich habe so den Eindruck, diese Mannschaft ist nicht in der Lage, mit Druck umzugehen, sei es positiv, sei es negativ. Ich kann mir nicht erklären, warum man so auseinanderfliegt, wenn man einen Gegentor bekommt. Ich verstehe es einfach nicht. Und jetzt um deine Frage mit Markus Fiedler. Ich persönlich würde es sehr begrüßen, wenn man noch an ihm festhält. Aber auch mir als jemand, der sehr große Stücke auf diesen Trainer hält und auch immer wieder verteidigt. Mir gehen so langsam auch die Argumente aus. Gerade auch, weil du es nicht schaffst, jetzt vier Spiele lang ein Tor zu erzielen. Das ist nun mal das Wichtigste im Fußball. Wir können über A-Noten und B-Noten sprechen. Letztendlich ist es entscheidend, dass sie Tore schießen. Und die machen wir nicht. Mir gehen so langsam auch die Ideen aus, was man da jetzt noch groß verändern könnte. Schwierig gerade, alles ganz, ganz schwierig.
So bodenlos ich Elbersberg falsch getippt habe in der Saison, so bestätigt fühle ich mich dann doch in meiner Magdeburg-Prognose. Weil ich eben das Gefühl hatte, dass ein außergewöhnlich guter Trainer für Zweitliga-Verhältnisse wie Christian Tietz einen eigentlich unterdurchschnittlichen Kader eben noch ans absolute Maximum geführt hat. Und sie hat überperformen lassen. Und jetzt kam der Wechsel im Sommer. Und ich glaube, zum einen konnte er nicht so ganz gut vorbereitet sein, weil sich diese Christian Tietz-Nummer ja auch gezogen hatte. Also dementsprechend, das spielt sicherlich mit rein. Aber ich fand, das war jetzt keine überzeugende Transferphase.
Nein.
Überhaupt nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Man hat sehr viele junge Spieler dazugeholt, das ist so ein bisschen das Nürnberg-Phänomen. Sehr viele junge Spieler dazugeholt. Oder Spieler, die Deutschland oder die 2. Liga nicht kennen. Nur können sie sich auch da nicht an einem Trainer festhalten, weil der die 2. Liga aus Trainer-Perspektive auch nicht kennt. So holt sie die ersten Ergebnisse nicht. Woher soll der Glaube kommen? Und dann entwickelt sich eine Negativ-Spirale, wo es wenig Spieler in diesem Kader gibt, würde ich sagen, die sich da wirklich effektiv gegenstemmen können. Und ich bleibe dabei und um Gottes Willen, der hat diese Mannschaft jahrelang geschultert. Das liegt nun alles nicht an ihm. Aber Baris Atik ist nicht mehr der Baris Atik von vor zwei, drei Jahren. Das ist er einfach nicht mehr. Und auch das hätte man in der Kaderplanung erkennen können, dass der Unterschiedspieler, den man hat, auch nicht mehr der Unterschiedspieler ist, der er mal war. Und das in Kombination führt mich einfach dazu, dass ich nicht viele Mannschaften sehe, die ich zwangsläufig hinter Magdeburg tippen würde. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass die Nummer vorbei ist. Um Gottes Willen, es ist viel zu spielen, es gibt eine Winterpause, du kannst korrigieren. Aber Stand jetzt, mach dir von außen nicht so viel Mut. Wie siehst du das, Anna?
Ich finde das schon sehr pessimistisch, muss ich sagen, weil ich sagen würde, bis das erste Gegentor fällt, ist das Spielere schon annehmbar und ansehnlich. Ich finde auch, die Chancen absolut, wirken weder zufällig, noch irgendwie rar, aber dann irgendwie erstaunlich kläglich vergeben. Und was jetzt auch in der Zusammenfassung, ich habe es mir eben im Vorfeld nochmal angeschaut, das dachte ich, krass, weil in den Saisons davor, klar, es gab immer diese Heimkrise, letzte Saison ja auch, also ich würde sogar so weit gehen, wenn man letzte Saison nicht so Schwierigkeiten gehabt hätte, zu Hause die gleiche Leistung zu bringen, dann wäre man wahrscheinlich sogar auswärts aufgestiegen.
Vielleicht auch wieder eine Druckfrage, auswärts in die Druck?
Ja, vielleicht, also da kennt man sich ja in Berlin auch, glaube ich, mit aus. Du hast überhaupt nicht was zu meinten. Halt, halt, halt, halt, halt. Überzeugen beschleunigen. Aber klar, vor allem relevant im Sommer ist natürlich der Abgang von Christian Hitz ja auch zu einem Verein, der nach oben möchte. Und ich glaube, wenn man jetzt auf die Tabelle sieht, guckt und schaut, welche Vereine spielen oben und welche spielen unten, dann hat man auch so eine Liga, in der relativ klar ist, wer kann wie klar welchen Anspruch formulieren. Elbersberg ist alles egal, das ist deren Vorteil, so spielen die auch.
Genau das.
Und bei den Vereinen, die nicht so genau wissen, so Magdeburg, Düsseldorf, Nürnbergs, dass Düsseldorf den Aufstieg ausruft, ist logisch im Hinblick auf die letzten Saisons. Aber ehrlich gesagt sehe ich das nicht, weil nach der Relegation kommt bei vielen Teams dieser Einbruch, den ich letzte Saison erwartet hatte, der jetzt diese Saison kommt, mit Ergebniskrisen und auch mit spielerischen Krisen. Und da war ich so ein bisschen überrascht, ehrlich gesagt, weil die ja auch viel gemacht haben im Sommer, dass man da sehr selbstbewusst irgendwie sagt, ja hier, wir wollen jetzt aber aufsteigen. Wie gesagt, ich kann das verstehen, weil was anderes kann man wahrscheinlich in dem Umfeld auch schwer verkaufen. Aber wenn ich mir jetzt Magdeburg angucke, das finde ich so schwer, weil du kannst ja nicht sagen, wir spielen um den Klassenerhalt. Das ist ja Quatsch. Aber wenn du sagst, wir spielen um den Aufstieg, ist ja genauso Quatsch. Und was macht man dann damit? Womit zündet man da wehen an? Wie hält man die Motivation von diesen Mittelfeldmannschaften aufrecht, die in der Bundesliga um einen internationalen Platz spielen würden, die ja die Liga super unterhaltsam machen, weil sie halt jeden Favoriten kippen können, die an meinem Ende dann aber doch nicht bis ganz nach oben kommen? Und das sehe ich im Moment bei Magdeburg halt total, weil nach der abgelaufenen Saison eigentlich der Blick nach oben, vielleicht sogar trotz Trainerwechsel, aber wäre zu ambitioniert gewesen, da hättest du halt voll mit auf die Fresse geflogen. Schwierig, super schwierig.
Thomas, du schüttelst vehement den Kopf, als Anna sagte, der Blick geht nach oben. Ist vielleicht auch, wen du fragst, aber wie war denn die... Gab es ein Saisonziel? Wurde das öffentlich formuliert?
Nein, nein, das machte Ottmar Schork schon, seit er davon redete, im zweiten Jahr, damals, nachdem wir aufgestiegen sind, eine sorgenfreie Saison zu spielen, die dann ja doch nicht so sorgenfrei war, wo dann noch sehr spät uns erst gerettet haben, hat er gesagt, er macht keine Prognosen mehr für so eine Saison. Aber grundsätzlich, im Umfeld und auch im Verein, hat hier keiner nach oben geguckt. Also man hat das schon sehr, sehr sauber eingeschätzt. Ottmar Schork hat ja auch gesagt, auf der Abschluss-PK der letzten Saison, ganz klar gesagt, wir sind Fünfter geworden, das ist ein super Ergebnis. Aber das ist natürlich auch der Tatsache geschuldet, dass viele Mannschaften, die eigentlich besser sind, als wir, auch schlechter waren. Also man hat das hier schon sehr, sehr sauber eingeschätzt. Und ich glaube, man war schon auch auf dem Standpunkt, dass man gesagt hat, das oberste Ziel hier in Magdeburg muss der Klassenerhalt sein. Alles andere ist vermessen. Wir sehen gerade, dass das auch richtig ist. Und von daher, das ist so meine große Hoffnung, die ich habe. Also das ist so tatsächlich da, wo ich mich jetzt inzwischen noch dran festhalte, dass man Ruhe warrt, dass man hier jetzt nicht in Aktionismus verfällt und dass man das eben auch vernünftig einschätzt im Gesetz zu manch anderem Verein.
Aber das ist ja cool. Also hätte ich jetzt tatsächlich so… Also aus Braunschweiger Warte habe ich mir so ein bisschen eifersüchtig nach Magdeburg geguckt, weil wir ja damals zusammen aufgestiegen sind und ich so, die kriegen das richtig gut hin. Die halten an dem Trainer fest, die halten die Stammspieler und die Leistungsträger, die entwickeln die Mannschaft, die Mannschaft spielt so gut. Klar, so bla bla bla bla bla. Und ich dachte immer, ich will gerne zu sein in Magdeburg. Und ich hatte jetzt irgendwie halt gedacht, dass der Verein sagt, okay, Platz 5, mal gucken, was da noch geht. Aber wenn du sagst, Klassen erhalt, das ist krass. Okay, ja, dann Wort.
Ja, gut. Jetzt hatten wir die Länderspielpause, um ein bisschen die Wunden zu lecken, den Reset-Knopf zu drücken. Da klingeln auch schon die Köpfe in Braunschweig. Man hat jetzt danach, der Länderspielpause, erstmal ein sehr schweres Auswärtsspiel in Darmstadt. Hat dann aber auch zwei wirklich, ich sag mal, zumindest für die Hinrunde, sehr entscheidende Duelle gegen Münster und Bochum. Also das wird ein interessanter Dreierpack, den dann Magdeburg zu bewältigen hat. Und vielleicht, vielleicht sieht die Welt dann ja schon anders aus. Aber apropos keine Saisonziele formulieren, das stößt uns quasi in den ersten Schwerpunkt der Folge. Denn das hat der Karlsruher SC auch nicht getan. Ganz bewusst vor der Saison hat da sich Mario Eggimann hingesetzt und gesagt, ne, machen wir nicht. Vielleicht auch, weil man weiß, wie eng diese Liga ist und der KSC einer von vielen ist. Aber lasst mich unten kurz euch in den ersten Schwerpunkt holen. Christian Eichner tut es schon wieder. Der KSC gehört wieder, wie in den letzten Jahren, früh zum Kandidatenkreis für den Bundesliga-Aufstieg. Nach 8 Spielen hat man 15 Punkte. So rum. Man hat erst ein Spiel verloren, steht damit auf Platz 7 nach 8 Spielen. Und hatte jetzt am Samstagabend ein spektakuläres 3 zu 3 gegen Dynamo Dresden, wo Karlsruhe übrigens quasi 33 Prozent seiner Saisongegentore kassiert hat. Man hatte davor nur 6, jetzt hat man 9. Ich will sagen, die Defensive ist wohl mal wieder das Prunkstück des KSC. Anna, ist es fair, wenn ich sage, eine gute Defensive und vorne regelt Martin Wannizek?
Ja, also, Freunde, hat er geschrieben, Martin Wannizek sei der Cheatcode für die 2. Liga. Und ich finde das schon frech, muss ich sagen. Also, dass die den zum einen so lange halten können, dass der sich zum anderen mit diesem Dienstältesten, soweit ich weiß, Trainer der Liga, so gut versteht. Das ist ja schon essentiell, dass du da einfach ein Draht in die Mannschaft hast und dann auch noch Leistungsträger und so weiter und so fort. Und dann performt er auch noch. Also, ganz im Ernst so.
Ja, für ja.
Ja, das ist einfach nicht in Ordnung. Das ist nicht.
Wer ist der Braunschweiger? Marvin Wannizek ist die.
Ja, das frage ich mich auch. Ich finde, ich bin so ein bisschen, ich bin ein bisschen ein geheimes Fangirl von Christian Eichner.
Ich auch. Oh, Fangirl. Kein Problem.
Okay, sehr gut. Ja, ich finde ihn cool. Ich hätte gerne jemanden wie Christian Eichner bei der Braunschweiger Eintracht, weil ich den auch so, ich habe das Gefühl, der macht das alles sehr professionell, aber der weiß immer noch, dass es irgendwie um Fußball geht. Und deswegen assoziere ich mit dem KSC immer so eine gewisse, sowas wie eine Leichtigkeit oder so. Und es erstaunt mich, dass sie das in so einer konstanten Konstellation tatsächlich aufrechterhalten können über die Jahre hinweg. Die haben das Stadion umgebaut, das sieht jetzt alles ein bisschen schicker aus. Und es fängt alles so ein bisschen nach und nach wieder alles an zu glänzen da in Karlsruhe. Und ja, also es ist tatsächlich eine Frage. Ich stelle sie mal hier und vielleicht können wir am Ende der Saison, äh, der Sendung darauf zurückkommen. Ich glaube, wir können gerade einen Kampf der Gezeiten in der 2. Liga beobachten. Und zwar, finde ich, gilt die 2. Liga mit dem Prototypen KSC als die Liga der eingespielten Teams, der Teams, die erfolgreich sind. Je länger ein Trainer im Amt ist, je länger das Team eingespielt ist. Und ich glaube, dass das gerade trifft auf Elvers Berge und Hanhofer Rana 96, die den Kader umbauen und einfach gut genug sind. Und diese eingespielt halt nicht mehr brauchen.
Das ist eine interessante Beobachtung tatsächlich. Da werde ich jetzt länger drüber nachdenken, passiv.
Aber wir wollten noch weiter über Katz vor sprechen. Richtig.
Aber ich möchte gerne ansetzen bei deinem Erstaunen, dass sie das so konstant hinbekloppen. Denn ich bin auch erstaunt, muss ich wirklich sagen. Weniger aufgrund von Christian Eichner. Im Gegenteil, ich halte Christian Eichner seit Jahren für einen der besten Trainer dieser Liga. So. In manchen Momenten war er gefühlt sogar der Beste. Und ohne einzelnen Spielern nahe treten zu wollen, zu nahe treten zu wollen, der KSC stellt in meinen Augen seit Jahren einen der schwächeren Kader der Liga. Abseits von Marvin Wainizek. Dem müssen wir ausklammern. Auch jetzt schon wieder bei zwei Toren, zwei Vorlagen. Man verliert oftmals im Sommer sogar eher an Qualität, als dass man besser wird. Auch in diesem Sommer fand ich die Transferphase nicht überzeugend. Man hat Max Weiß für viel Geld verkauft, hat dafür Bernat geholt, der tatsächlich ja gut funktioniert. Und es ist ja weniger, es hängt bei mir auf weniger den Spielern, die man geholt hat. Also auch ein Müller funktioniert, ein Förster ist ein guter Transfer. Alles gut. Es geht eher darum, wen man nicht geholt hat. Denn der Kader ist in meinen Augen echt dünn. Die Bank kann kaum einen Unterschied machen. Das war letztes Jahr schon eigentlich so. Und auch da hat man Christian Eichhner schon, ja, manchmal auch ein bisschen hadern hören, hatte ich das Gefühl. Und das ist dieses Jahr nicht besser geworden. Und ich finde, dass der KSC trotzdem wieder oben mitspielt, trotzdem wieder so überzeugt. Das ist alles keine Selbstverständlichkeit. Und ich sehe den Tag, an dem Christian Eichhner vielleicht für höhere Aufgaben wegzieht. So ein bisschen wie in Magdeburg. Und dann kommt ein neuer Trainer und du stellst fest, ach du Scheiße, das ist ja doch alles nicht so selbstverständlich, was wir hier haben. Weil auch Marvin Wanicek wird nicht jünger und Ähnliches. Und ich muss sagen, ich glaube, du hast es schon richtig gesagt, mit dem Stadion und so weiter passiert auch einiges. Aber es hängt alles irgendwie so ein bisschen an den seidenen Faden. Eichhner, Wanicek habe ich das Gefühl. Und wenn die loslassen, dann kann es auch in eine ganz andere Richtung gehen beim KSC. Aber vielleicht, bevor ich das ganz Große aufmache, Thomas, was machen sie denn spielerisch in diesem Jahr für dich für einen Eindruck? Dasselbe wie immer? Oder wo liegen ihre Stärken in deinen Augen?
Im Grunde schon eigentlich. Das selbe wie in den letzten Jahren. Für mich war das– also ich muss sagen, für mich ist das keine Überraschung. Ich habe KSC auch vor der Saison bei uns hier als Aufsteige getippt. Mal gucken, was da richtig eintrifft. Ich finde schon, für mich waren die letzten Saison schon Kandidat, bis sie dann im Winter den Fehler gemacht haben, Zivci-Date zu verkaufen. Dann wären die letzten Saison schon hochgegangen, wenn die den behalten hätten können. Was der KSC eben einfach kann, und ich glaube, das ist genau das, was du in dieser Liga brauchst, das mag sein, dass man auch mit Offensiven, ich sage jetzt mal ein bisschen überspitzt, schönspielfußball, auch viel Erfolg haben kann. Aber ich glaube schon, die Grundlage auch in dieser Liga ist, defensiv gut zu stehen. Das hat sich letzte Saison gezeigt, dass Köln mit den wenigsten Gegentoren aufgestiegen ist. Das ist ja kein Zufall. Wir hatten 20 Tore mehr als Köln, haben aber auch 15 weniger kassiert oder mehr kassiert. Köln ist aber wieder aufgestiegen. Und ich glaube, das ist so die Grundlage. Und die ist in Karlsruhe einfach da. Diese defensive Stabilität, die die haben, gepaart mit einem, finde ich, guten Umschaltspiel oder sehr guten Umschaltspiel. Und dann eben aber auch in selberer Lage, auch mit bei selber was zu tun. Jetzt vielleicht nicht so spektakulär, wie das Hannover macht, aber grundsätzlich ist das einfach eine Mannschaft, die passt zusammen. Das ist eine gut aufeinander abgestimmte Mannschaft. Die Rädchen greifen ineinander. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, ein ganz großer Schlüssel ist Christian Eichner. Definitiv. Und ich finde, ein ganz großer Faktor ist einfach auch der Umstand. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das erinnern könnt. Vor zwei Jahren gab es doch schon mal diese Diskussionen, auch geht da, geht da nicht. Da war ja schon durchaus auch Thema. Und ich glaube, das hat den KSC auch nochmal Stärke gemacht. Diese ganze Diskussion, dass er dann auch geblieben ist und dann eben auch gesagt hat, ich gehe jetzt diesen Weg in Karlsruhe weiter. Dass man eben einfach gesehen hat, Mensch, wir können den Trainer dann doch am Ende überzeugen, hier zu bleiben. Und sie spielen ja auch letzte Saison, finde ich, bis zum Wechsel von Zifti dazu waren sie gut dabei. Dann sind sie so ein bisschen eingebrochen in der Rückrunde. Aber diese Mannschaft ist für mich einfach ein Phänomen, was dieses wirklich abgestimmt auf diese… Die passen einfach super in diese 2. Bundesliga, finde ich. Da ist alles da, was du brauchst. Die sind kopfballstark, das mussten wir leider Gottes sehen. Die können mit Ball am Fuß, Umschaltspiel wie gesagt, und mit Vanicek, ihr habt es gesagt. Mit Vanicek glaube ich einfach auch ein Spieler, der kann dir jedes Spiel einen Unterschied machen. Vielleicht nicht immer so, dass es immer was bringt, aber der hat immer eine Idee, da ist immer irgendwas da, wenn der im Ball ist, muss immer mit irgendwas rechnen. Das ist eben so ein Spieler, die sich in der Liga nicht so häufig sucht, dann hat man dann doch mehr. Deswegen ist das für mich in Karlsruhe auch eine Geschichte, die durchaus gut weiterlaufen kann, trotz dieses dünnen Kars, da hast du vollkommen recht. Und man hat da eben auch den Luxus, man kann da eben auch ein 18er-Olympiade-Rosa reinschmeißen, der dann auch super Leistung bringt. Das läuft da einfach gerade alles. Ich finde, wenn die so weitermachen, dann ist das für mich tatsächlich, wie sagt man im Englischen, so ein Dark Horse. Die sind da für mich jetzt eine Truppe, die da oben auch bleiben werden, wenn man nicht wieder im Winter ein wichtiges Spieler verliert. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die bis zum Ende auf jeden Fall um diesen Aufstieg mitspielen werden.
Ich glaube, viele sehr gute Punkte genannt. Ich glaube, was mit der damaligen Diskussion und dem letztendlichen Verbleib von Christian Eichen auch zusammenhing, ich hatte da auch das Gefühl, dass er Dinge gefordert hat, dass er eben nicht stehen bleiben möchte. Seitdem hat sich ja beim KSC auch personell was getan. Man hat ja den sportlichen Bereich auch umgestellt. Man hat im Sommer jetzt auch Timon Pauls, der war Kaderplaner bei Hertha, der ist jetzt Sportdirektor beim KSC. Also man hat sich da auch anders und breiter aufgestellt. Und vielleicht gibt auch das Eichner ein Gefühl von, okay, wir bleiben nicht stehen, wir verändern Dinge. Die laufen vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer, weil hier sehr konservativ ja auch gewirtschaftet wird und ähnliches, aber vielleicht bewegt sich da im Kleinen, was man von außen manchmal vielleicht auch nicht so sieht, Dinge, die funktionieren. Dann wiederum bei dem, was du auf dem Rasen angesprungen hast, das gehe ich mit, ich verbinde mit dem KSC, diese Mannschaft ist in allen Bereichen mindestens solide. Die kann aus dem Ballbesitz heraus was entwickeln, die presst ordentlich, die kann teils echt gut umschalten, die kann aber auch im tiefen Block gut verteidigen. Sie haben gute Dreiecksbildung im Halbraum, also haben da auch spielintelligente Spieler, wie natürlich vor allen Dingen Warnizek, aber auch ein Ecklauf ist zum Beispiel super dafür, der sich in so Halbräumen dann intelligent bewegt. Louis-Ben Fahd ja auch. Und Ben Fahd ist dann auch wiederum ein gutes Stichwort, denn du hast auch Pedro Rosa zum Beispiel angesprochen. Er schafft das eben dann auch, Spieler weiterzuentwickeln, die dann im Sommer wieder für viel Geld gehen können. Max Weiß natürlich eine eigene Personalie, weil Torhüter, da weiß man nie genau, wie viel ist da noch am Torwart Trainer. Ich glaube, Markus Miller ist es beim KSC, hängt da dran. Aber man schafft es zumindest Jahr für Jahr mittlerweile wieder. Ich glaube, das zwischendurch hat die auch ein bisschen eingeschlafen, wieder Eigengewächse zu produzieren, mit denen man viel Geld machen kann. Und das ist nun mal auch ein sehr gangbarer Weg in der 2. Liga, um wirtschaftlich zu gesunden. Deswegen finde ich, sowohl auf dem Platz als auch daneben wirkt alles irresolide beim KSC. Wie gesagt, es hängt schon krass an Christian Eichner, glaube ich, aber das macht das nicht wett. Und ich glaube auch, dass der KSC diese Saison eine echt gute Rolle spielen kann. Ich glaube, dass er relativ lange oben dabei sein kann. Ich glaube aber, es wird wie in den letzten Jahren sein, ich finde den Kader nach wie vor dünn. Und ich halte ihn für so dünn, dass sie letztendlich doch nicht ganz oben anklopfen können. Und dass ihnen vielleicht doch eher die Puste ausgeht. Und man muss immer hoffen, dass Marvin Wanicek heile bleibt. Was passiert, wenn der mal sich verletzt? Das kommt ja auch dazu, dass man da angehend, was heißt Glück, hängt ja auch mit einer eigenen Vorbereitung und Vorbeugung und so zusammen. Aber in den letzten Jahren habe ich das Gefühl, war er nun nicht so oft verletzt. Aber solche Spieler müssen jetzt natürlich fit bleiben. Louis-Ben Verhardt fällt aktuell, glaube ich, einen Mittelfußbruch aus. Also der ist gerade nicht dabei. Aber dann kriegt er es irgendwie hin, Eichner, dass ein Fahlbeeren-Schleusener mit 33 Jahren doch noch mal zündet und jetzt bei drei Saisontoren steht. Also, ja, will sagen, vielleicht war es ganz gut, keinen Saisontor auszurufen, weil du eben weißt, wie viel an einzelnen Personalien hängt und auch, wie schnell sich einzelne junge Spieler weiterentwickeln. Auch ein Rocco Simic beispielsweise, den sie ja im Sommer geholt haben. Junger, kroatischer Mittelstürmer, 22 Jahre alt. Karriereknick irgendwie drin, den haben sie jetzt geliehen. Der kann auch ein Unterschiedspieler sein, aber der muss halt erst mal ankommen. So und insgesamt ist das alles schon wieder irre solide. Und trotzdem glaube ich persönlich nicht. Anna, du kannst da gerne auch mal deinen Senf noch dazugeben. Dass es letztendlich für ganz oben reichen wird.
Ja, also ich würde mich gerne in die Pferdemetaphern einreihen. Gerade schon das Dark Horse genannt worden. Ich würde gerne das gute Pferd ins Rennen schicken, das so hochspringt, wie es muss.
Habt ihr schon kurz irgendwelche Angst vor irgendwelchen Hengst-Vergleichen?
Nein, nein, nein. Um Gottes Willen. Vor Christian Eichhna habe ich Respekt, das mache ich nicht. Und zwar habe ich hier gerade meinen Blick auf die bisherige Saison vom KSC. Und ich habe den Eindruck, wenn die halt gegen Teams wie uns spielen, gegen Eintracht Braunschweig, dann machen die das 2-0 zu Hause. Nicht alle schwitzen und das reicht so. Und wenn sie jetzt auswärts gegen Dresden spielen, muss man sich schon insgesamt ein bisschen mehr strecken. Das tun sie dann aber auch. Also die drei Tore schaffen sie. Sie kassieren aber eben auch drei. Ich finde es sehr, sehr interessant, dass sie– oder bzw. ich lasse es mich so formulieren– ich bin gespannt, was passiert, wenn sie jetzt gegen die bisschen stärkeren Teams der Liga spielen. Weil gegen die Hertha haben sie gespielt, als es alles noch ein bisschen schwierig war in Berlin. Das hat sich ja heute geändert. Oder gestern. Das waren 0-0. Und ansonsten sind die Sieger eingefahren. Gegen Magdeburg kriselnd, gegen Nürnberg kriselnd, gegen Braunschweig kriselnd, gegen Münster in Überzahl Last-Minute zu Hause am ersten Spieltag. Und gegen Kiel gab es 3-0 auf die Mütze. Also mal schauen, was da passiert. Weil, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, dann kämpfen die so ein bisschen um den Ballbesitz. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass das gar nicht so unmodern ist aktuell, die Kontrolle ja abzugeben, weil sich eben die spielschwächeren Teams in der Liga einfach sehr schwer tun mit dem Ball. Und die besseren Teams sagen ja hier, macht ihr mal, könnt ihr nicht, okay, dann gewinnen wir. Das ist zumindest das, was ich leider in unseren Spielen sehr häufig zu beobachten meine.
Ich glaube zumindest, weil der KSC sich trotzdem den Luxus erlauben kann, dass bei einem unentschieden gegen ein schwächeres Team auch keiner aufmuckt.
Genau. Ja, ja. Aber wie gesagt, ich bin gespannt. Jetzt spielen die gegen Kaiserslautern, dann kommt noch Schalke, Elbersberg, Hannover, Darmstadt, Paderborn und so.
Ja, guter Punkt. Passt ja auch zu deren Umschaltspiel. Also es ist irgendwie, wie man es nimmt. Einerseits schwerere Gegner, andererseits passt vielleicht besser zum eigenen Stil. Deswegen wird es sehr spannend sein, wo die dann am Ende der Hinrunde stehen. So, dementsprechend wollen wir jetzt den Paar zum KSC zumachen und sprechen jetzt über ein Team, das– ja, also im Gegensatz zum KSC, da würde ich eher sagen alles neu. Also da hat sich viel verändert und dieses Team ist Preußen Münster. Auch da hole ich euch einmal kurz ab. Ja, nach dem durchaus spektakulären Klassenhalt letztes Jahr, zumindest zu den letzten Spielen weiß ich noch. Christian, Panda und Co., ihr erinnert euch. Entschied sich Münster für einen radikalen Umbruch im Sommer. Mit Alexander Ende kam ein neuer Trainer aus Verl, mit einer gänzlich anderen Spielidee, als man es bisher aus Münster kannte. Flaches, dominantes Ballbesitzspiel sollte es plötzlich sein. Dazu ein neuer Kader, zehn neue Spieler, elf Abgänge, ambitionierte Transfers finde ich wie Tikvic, der fällt leider mit dem Kreuzband-Triss direkt aus. Aber auch so Spieler wie Batista Maier, Jeckel, Wilhelm Sohn, Marvin Schulz sind vielleicht Transfers, die man Preußen Münster so nicht zugetraut hätte vor dem Sommer. Und nach 8 Spielen würde ich das vorsichtige Zwischenfazit mal reinwerfen. Der Umbuch ist gelungen. 10 Punkte nach 8 Spielen sind in Ordnung. Auch weil man jetzt schon gegen KSC, Paderborn, Lauten und Hertha gespielt hat. Also da sind wiederum einige schwerere Gegner schon mal weg. Münster spielt mit den schönsten Ballen in der Liga, drittwister Wahlbesitz, beste Passquote, immer wieder sehr gute spielerische Lösung und Passstaffetten auf engem Raum. Also diese enge Mittelfeldraute, die funktioniert gut, hat auch ihre Schwächen. Das hat man jetzt auch, da leite ich vielleicht kurz zu dem Spieltag über, jetzt gegen Hertha gesehen. Denn das, muss man sagen, ist vielleicht das eine Problem oder zwei Probleme, die man bislang unter Ende hat. Hertha hat, und das war auch die Blaupause für Kaiserslautern, die ja über Münster rübergerollt sind, Hertha hat ganz schnöde Mann-Deckungen im Mittelfeld gespielt. Die haben einfach 1 zu 1 verteidigt in der Mittelfeldraute. Und das hat schon mal den Spielaufbau von Münster lahmgelegt. Und das andere Thema ist gegen den Ball. Vertikale Verlagerungen fallen, also tun einer engen Raute natürlich super weh, weil du auf dem Flügel selten gut besetzt bist. Das hat Hertha sehr, sehr gut gemacht, hat das Spielfeld sehr breit gemacht, sehr vertikal verlagert. Darauf hat Münster keine Antwort gefunden. Man ist immer wieder über den Flügel durchgebrochen. Und am Ende hatte Hertha einen fast schon aberwitzigen, besonders wenn man die bisherige Saison sieht, aberwitzigen Expected Goals-Wert von 4,8. Also das hätte auch wirklich, und das hätte anders ausgehen müssen. Es gab Phasen, in denen Hertha locker das 3-4-5-0 hätte machen können. Das wäre vollkommen okay gewesen. Und das sind sicherlich noch Probleme, die Münster hat. Aber genug meiner Rede. Anna, ich habe mir Münster jetzt noch mal angeguckt und auch da vielleicht der Fährvergleich auf Braunschweig. Ich dachte mir so, ist das vielleicht etwas, was Braunschweig sich auch wünschen würde, mal in einem Sommer so ein Karschlag und zu sagen, ey, ne, wir trennen uns jetzt von diesem, wir überleben jetzt einfach Fußball und entwickeln etwas, was irgendwie mitreißt und Vision hat? Wie neidisch blickst du nach Münster, auch wenn natürlich der Saisonstart noch mit Vorsicht genossen werden muss?
Es geht eigentlich, weil ich den Eindruck habe, das haben wir alles versucht und es hat nicht funktioniert. Was aber unterschiedlichste Gründe hat, weil du natürlich in Münster jetzt die Situation hast, die sind letzte Saison aufgestiegen, die starten jetzt in die zweite Zweitliga-Saison, es ist seit über 30 Jahren nicht der Fall gewesen, dass da zweite Liga gespielt wird, zwei Jahre hintereinander. Die bauen ein neues Stadion, eine Tribüne ist jetzt fertig, also hurra hurra, wir wollen hier richtig cool was aufbauen. Das ist halt eine ganz andere Stimmung als depressiv zwischen Harz und Heide blau und gelb zu tragen. Nichtsdestotrotz, das, was ich neide, ist so dieser Entscheidungsmut tatsächlich. Also die haben Sascha Hildmann ja mitten im Abstiegskampf entlassen und ich habe so gedacht, aiaiai, war ja direkte Konkurrenz letzte Saison, ist das echt so smart, weil ich immer den Eindruck hatte, der hat ja sehr destruktiv gespielt und Anti-Fußball oder wie man das auch immer nennen möchte. Und ich habe aber gedacht, ja, aber das musst du doch machen. Du musst doch so spielen, wenn du im Abstiegskampf in der 2. Liga bestehen möchtest. Das geht doch gar nicht anders. Und ging sehr gut anders. Die haben dann direkt die Klasse gehalten, ohne Umweg über Relagation oder sonst wem. Wir krisen jetzt auch nicht super komfortabel und nicht ohne Geräusch. Aber das hat mir schon wirklich imponiert. Und ich habe gedacht, okay, krass. Also da vielleicht schon, Stichwort Neid, ein bisschen gespürt dieses Out-of-the-Box-Denken oder es einfach mal zu probieren oder dem Verein auch zuzutrauen, auch dem Umfeld zuzutrauen. Und ich glaube, das Ergebnis ist jetzt ein Team, das wahrscheinlich nicht ganz ohne Geräusch, aber die Klasse halten wird. Also ich finde dieses unentschieden Lose, es gibt noch ein Unentschieden gegen Paderborn, immerhin, ey, zweiten Spieltag und sonst eins oder null. Und das finde ich total smart. Wirklich. Also versucht er, rein rechnisch ist es auf drei Punkte in einem Spiel. Und ich meine jetzt auch, er ging also jetzt auswärts im Olympiastadion, hattet ihr zwar die viel besseren Chancen mit dem höheren Expected Goals Wert, aber die kommen schon auch zu Abschlüssen. Also es ist so, das war so ein Spiel von Hertha macht die Dinger vorne nicht. Und ich hab zwischendurch, hab ich gedacht, ich glaube die ergaunern da noch irgendwie so ein 2-2. Und hab dann die PK gehört und war sehr amüsiert über einen extrem schlecht gelaunten Trainer, der glaube ich wirklich so ein Zornes Falten gegerbt, da er seinen Rückweg angetreten hat. Und da hab ich gedacht, ja, okay, ja, also klar verloren, aber ja auch irgendwie, ne, vor welcher Kulisse und gegen welchen Gegner und so.
Das ist schon peinlich, gegen Hertha in Berlin zu verlieren.
Ja, okay, naja. Ich glaube, ich hab immer Löwersteiner noch nie auch nur Punkte geholt, aber ich weiß es nicht, genau. Insofern, ich bin ehrlich gesagt, wir haben ja auch schon gegen Münster gespielt, in Münster. Und ich war voll überrascht, weil ich das Gefühl hatte, ich spiele gegen richtigen Zweitligisten und nicht gegen, ach ja, zweite Saison, wie wird das? Ich finde, die machen das richtig, richtig gut.
Oder wie Toni Leisner nach dem Pokalspiel gegen Münster sagte, ich dachte die ersten 20 Minuten, wir spielen gegen Barcelona.
Ja, oder so.
Was irgendwie auch so ein echt kleines Mindset ist als Hertha-Spieler. Aber man muss sagen, Münster hat damals Hertha im Pokalspiel nach Belieben dominiert. Das war wirklich krass. Das lag natürlich auch an einem desolaten Hertha, lag aber auch daran, dass Münster es bespielen konnte. Und ich habe die jetzt auch schon mehrmals in Konferenzen gesehen. Ich habe sie jetzt 90 Minuten gesehen. Die können richtig fein Ball spielen. Also das muss man wirklich sagen, haben da sehr konsequent den Kader auch nach umgebaut. Also kann es ja nicht einfach den Fußball über den bestehenden Kader stülpen und sagen, macht mal, sondern haben da mit Battista Meyer, der ja auch ein alter Vertrauter ist, fair ist mit Alexander Ende, Spieler geholt, die diese Spielidee umsetzen können, haben mit Wilhelms so einen Tiefgang dazu gewonnen. Steht ja, glaube ich, auch bei drei Saisontoren oder zwei. Also ich finde schon, da klicken gewisse Dinge. Ich hatte für meinen Job jetzt für den Vorbericht mit Carsten Schulte geredet, der vom Preußen-Journal, der also Preußen-Münster-Experte ist seit Jahrzehnten. Und der meinte, im Moment ist die Fußballwelt in Münster wirklich in Ordnung. Also wir haben auf der einen Seite den mitreißenden Fußball, der einfach toll ist und Spaß macht. Aber auf der anderen Seite stehen alle Dinge, die so infrastrukturell und personell sind. Und da macht Münster auch sehr, sehr viel richtig. Also es ist so, du hast das Stadion schon angesprochen, da ist man sogar wohl sogar vor Zeit planen an aktuell ist es so, Ende 27 sollte das Stadion dann mit 19.000 Zuschauern fertig sein. Es könnte aber auch früher passieren. Man konnte jetzt irgendeine Tribüne früher öffnen, als es eigentlich der Fall gewesen sein soll. Man hatte jetzt die Zahlen des vergangenen Geschäftsjahres veröffentlicht und hatten einen Gewinn in Höhe von 3,5 Millionen Euro ausgeben können. Der Verein ist de facto schuldenfrei, also es wird wahnsinnig gut gewirtschaftet. Thomas, das kennst du aus Magdeburg auch und weißt, dass das ja ein wichtiger Rahmen, den man sich da gibt. Dazu kommt, dass man auch personell wächst aus diesem wirtschaftlichen Boom heraus. Man hat jetzt auch die sportliche Leitung ganz neu besetzt und hat da jetzt Leute, die man vorher nicht hatte. Ich glaube, man hat sowohl Geschäftsführersport als auch Sportdirektor– nee, andersrum. Sportdirektor und Kaderplaner hat man jetzt neu besetzt, um den Geschäftsführer zu entlasten. Man stellt sich auch da breiter auf. Heißt noch nicht, dass die alle super duper sind, das weiß man natürlich nicht. Aber da ist ein Expansionsgedanke zumindest vorhanden. Und mutige Entscheidungen, wie du es genannt hast, werden da getroffen. Thomas, was macht Münster für einen Gesamteindruck auf dich?
Ja, ich glaube, mit dem Ende haben sie natürlich auch einen Trainer geholt, der schon durch seine Zeit in den Ferner auch so ein bisschen schon einen Eindruck hinterlassen hat. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass der zumindest so in dem einen oder anderen Kreisen auch bei uns mal genannt wurde, zumindest durchaus. Also da war klar, glaube ich schon, der Weg geht in die 2. Liga, dass Münster sich jetzt angehen konnte. Ja, schön für Münster. Und ich glaube auch, was Anna gesagt hat, die wirken nicht so wie dieses typische zweite Jahr. Normalerweise bringt man da auch immer Mensch. Das wird schwierig, aber das wirkt alles sehr, sehr stabil. Also ich habe da auch das Spiel gegen Paderborn gesehen von Münster in den 90 Minuten und musste auch sagen, das, was ich da gesehen habe, hat mir schon gefallen. Also das ist auch da ein klarer Plan. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was dann solche Mannschaften auch immer dann so ein bisschen ausmacht. Das ist auch das, was Elvesbear, glaube ich, gerade sehr ausmacht. Da ist ein klarer Plan vorhanden und von dem weicht man grundsätzlich nicht ab, ist aber durchaus in der Lage. Und das ist eben das, was mir dann immer so gefällt, dass Trainer auch dann pragmatisch mal an Sachen rangehen und sagen, naja, gut, nee, das funktioniert jetzt vielleicht in dem Spiel nicht so, wir werden jetzt mal ein bisschen was verändern. Und dass dann solche Spiele, wie du das angesprochen hast, wie jetzt in Berlin, dass man da dann auch mal taktisch so ein bisschen, ich sage jetzt mal so, auf die Fresse fliegt, mit der Raut und mit den vielen Durchbrüchen, die man außen die Härte hatte. Das sind dann auch Lerndeffekte, die der Trainer auch mitnehmen wird. Und ich glaube, das wird der Grund sein, bin ich absolut auch anders Meinung, dass man am Ende in Münster wahrscheinlich einen relativ souveränen Klassenhalt erleben wird, ohne groß jemals in der Saison in Abstiegnöte zu geraten. Von daher, das wirkt alles auch sehr, sehr ruhig dort. Auch diese ganze, wie man das moderiert hat die letzte Saison, als man den Trainer noch mal getauscht hat. Das war alles, das wirkt jetzt nicht so. Man hat ja so den Eindruck, Bochum mal als Beispiel, finde ich, das war jetzt einfach Aktionismus pur, meine Meinung nach. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass man mit Uwe Rösler jetzt an den großen Volltreffer landen wird. Und das ist dann Münster eben nicht passiert. Und da hat man im Sommer viele Stellschrauben gedreht, die jetzt funktionieren und kann man sich eigentlich nur freuen, wenn man da jetzt mal ganz neutral drauf guckt, dass ein Verein wie Münster eben auch in der 2. Liga so weit angekommen ist, dass man da jetzt hohe Warten eben einfach den nächsten Schritt machen will und das scheinbar auch schafft.
Sehr schön. Nächsten Schritt gehen wir jetzt auch und gehen zu Holstein Kiel. Auch geil, ich habe eigentlich im Vorgespräch angekündigt, wir gehen das tabellarisch durch, ich bin einfach mal im Dokument verrutscht. Also Preußen Münster steht noch nicht vor Holstein Kiel, wobei das jetzt auch nicht so weit auseinander ist. Also ich glaube, der nächste Spiel, da könnte das auch schon kippen. Aber da sind wir jetzt nicht. Wir sind bei Holstein Kiel. Die stehen eigentlich hinter dem KSC. Zumindest in unserer 5-Club-Tabelle. Lasst mich euch da auch einmal kurz abholen. Die Kieler Störche beendeten die letzte Erstligasaison, ihre erste Erstligasaison, mit 25 Punkten auf Rang 17. Es ging also direkt wieder runter. Doch der Klub- und Trainer Marcel Rapp ging gemeinsam in die Zukunft. Er verlängerte noch in der Saison bis 2028. Man entscheidet sich also für eine gemeinsame Zukunft. Anders sah es im Kader aus. Da gab es nach dem Abstieg einen ziemlich großen Kaderumbruch. Leute wie Maschino, Remberg, Pichler, Porat, Fiete Abt, Timo Becker, Lewis Holtby– die Gesichter der letzten Jahre sind alle weg. Dafür nahm Kiel aber auch immerhin rund 15 Millionen Euro ein. Und von der alten Truppe bei mir so Leute wie Steven Skripski, Bernadson, Commander, Timon Weiner. Dafür kamen aber auch gleichzeitig 13 neue Spiele an die Förde. Also vor allen Dingen so Spieler wie Jonas Terkelsen, Caspar Davidsen, Kapralnik, Rosling, Stefan Schwab. Das sollen jetzt so die neuen Gesichter sein, die neuen Korsett-Stangen für die Zukunft. Der Saisonstart, ich würde sagen, lief durchwachsen. 10 Punkte nach 8 Spielen, damit wird Kiel nicht zufrieden sein. Vor allem das große Problem ist, die Konstanz fehlt. Man hat erst zwei Spiele hintereinander nicht verloren. Das waren auch dann gleich zwei Siege. Und Rab sagte auch jetzt zum Saisonstart, seit Saisonbeginn haben wir deutliche Schritte nach vorne gemacht. Wir müssen dennoch Konstanzen in unsere Leistungen bringen. Wir haben alle das Gefühl, dass mehr drin ist. Daran müssen wir weiter arbeiten. Olaf Rebbe schlug in dieselbe Kerbe. Anna, was für ein Eindruck macht den Kiel jetzt nach dem Abstieg auf dich? Wie gefestigt ist das? Wie weit muss man sich vielleicht von der Reihenpunkte aus heute trennen, um Kiel fair bewerten zu können?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Der Start war natürlich komplett katastrophal mit, ich glaube, zwei Niederlagen oder drei sogar. Zwei Niederlagen gegen Paderborn und Bielefeld. Und da hatte ich irgendwie schon so, was heißt die Sorge? Ich habe jetzt kein besonders emotionales Verhältnis zu Kiel, aber dachte so, oh krass, mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt, weil man ja irgendwie in der Vergangenheit an Bielefeld, aber jetzt diese Saison auch an Bochum sieht, dass Absteigen nicht einfach ist. Und dass man wirklich vorsichtig sein muss mit dem Erwartungsmanagement, wie geht man in diese Saison rein, welchen Kader baut man, baut man einen Zweitligakader, baut man einen Zweitligakader, der sich entwickeln soll in Richtung eines Aufstiegskaders. Das sind also Ideen, weil das sind ja alles Profis, die hoffentlich, weil sie Profis sind, nicht von diesem Sommer bis zum nächsten Plan, sondern mit ein bisschen Voraussicht. Und ich mir schon vorstellen kann, dass Kiel Bock hat, wieder Bundesliga zu spielen, mittelfristig zumindest, oder sich da einfach relativ weit oben zu etablieren. Was ich spannend finde, ist, ich habe mir jetzt im Vorfeld die Pressekonferenzen angehört, nach den Spielen, und dass alle Trainer der jeweiligen Kiel Gegner komplett schwärmen und beschreiben, was das für ein toller Fußball sei und wie gut da gearbeitet wird. Und dass das, also Christian Eichner sagte, glaube ich, dass das irgendwie eine Kombination aus Individualität und taktischer Disziplin ist, die er so in dieser Saison noch nicht getroffen hat. Na ja, auch direkt in 3-0 verloren. Aber natürlich, wie du sagst, da sind dann eben auch Spiele wie gegen Elbersberg dabei, wo einfach wirklich sehr wenig funktioniert, vor allem die Konsequenz nach vorne einfach gar nicht da ist. So richtig defensive Einbrüche hatten sie bisher nicht, also jetzt keine komplette Klatsche bekommen, aber natürlich eben schon irgendwie Niederlagen einstecken müssen. Das, was ich auffällig fand jetzt in dem Spiel gegen Darmstadt, dass sie aus Dominanz nicht zweifelsfrei Tore oder sogar Siege gewinnen können, weil sie das Spiel ja absolut im Griff hatten. Also Darmstadt hat ja nichts gemacht und dann irgendwie mit einer wirklich Traumtor-Aktion in Führung gegangen. Und dann reicht es noch zum Ausgleich immerhin. Aber eigentlich, das Spiel, also, warum sind das nicht unglaublich?
22 zu 8 Torschüsse, 2,37 zu 0,61.
Das ist komplett absurd. Und ich glaube, dass sie das abstellen können, weil sie ja auch schon wirklich essenzielle Anpassungen vorgenommen haben. Sie haben ein Spiel kompakter gemacht nach den ersten Spielen, die halt so gar nicht gut liefen, denken mehr vertikal inzwischen in die Tiefe und versuchen halt alles, um da ihre Zielspieler in Szene zu setzen. Aber so richtig zu greifen, scheint es noch nicht.
Ich glaube, das sind ganz normale Wachstumsschmerzen eines Umbruchs. Ich finde schon, dass du Rappfußball erkennst. Und es ist eben das auf der einen Seite Momente lassen für Individualität. Also vor allen Dingen so ein Bernardson möchtest du ja auch sein Ding machen lassen. Dann kann dieser Unterschiedsspieler in dieser Liga sein. Sehr krass, dass du den auch halten konntest, nachdem der ja auch einer der Spieler war, der in der ersten Liga schon gezündet hat. Man setzt weiter auf Dreierkette, man setzt aber vor allen Dingen auf sehr fluide Formationshochraden. Also Spieler tauchen überall auf. Das hast du jetzt auch gehabt, dass plötzlich dann Zack, der Innenverteidiger, vorne auftaucht und ein wunderschönes Tor schießt. Aber das passiert, weil so gut durchgeschoben wird, dass er diese Freiheiten hat, da mal aufzutauchen. Und das zieht sich, das war auch genau der Stil, der Kiel in die erste Liga gebracht hat. Also, dass das ein super gutes Kollektiv war, taktisch. Auch gegen den Ball, richtig schwer zu knacken. Man hat auch jetzt erst acht Gegentore kassiert. Also mit den besten Defensivwerten zumindest, was die Gegentore angeht. Und man ist nach Expected Goals viertbester Club der Liga. Sprich, man belohnt sich einfach insgesamt noch nicht oft genug. Man hat aber, fände ich auch nicht, also wenn ich mir diesen Kader angucke von Kiel, dann sehe ich da auch nicht den klaren Torjäger. Also ja, Steven Skripski ist zu einer zweisligen Toranzahl in der zweiten Liga befähigt. Aber das ist jetzt auch kein Spieler, wo ich sage, das muss passieren. Und dann hast du eher so Spieler wie Phil Harris, der ja durchaus einen kometenhaften Aufstieg hatte aus der Regionalliga in die erste Liga, aber das ja auch in der zweiten Liga noch nicht auf Jahre bewiesen hat. Also dir fehlt so ein bisschen der Stürmer, wo du sagst, ja natürlich trifft er zweistellig. So und das zeigt sich bislang in dem Saisonstart, wie ich finde, dass du da ja noch Anpassungsprobleme hast, beziehungsweise Spieler wie Kapralnik und so. Kapralnik, die sind ja auch noch jung. Also Phil Harris ist 23, Kapralnik ist 23, Markus Müller, den sie aus einer Brücke holten, ist 23. Generell ist der Kader jung, auch Jonas Terkelsen, der Königstransfer des Sommers, zumindest was die Transfer-Summe angeht, ist glaube ich 22. Also dieser Kader ist jetzt so umgebrochen worden, dass da gibt es sehr viel Perspektive im Kader. Auch im Tor haben sie auf Krummreihe zum Beispiel gesetzt, 21. Also das zieht sich echt durch den Kader durch. Und Thomas, ich haue mal jetzt meinen Take für die Kiel-Saison jetzt schon mal raus und kannst dann sagen, wie du sie siehst und ob du das anders siehst. Ich glaube, diese Saison muss sich Kiel noch finden. Diese Saison, das hat der Saisonstart gezeigt, wird Kiel eher ein Team für die obere Tabellenhälfte sein. Annehmbaren Fußballspielen, teilweise sogar sehr guten Fußballspielen, aber ich glaube, dass Kiel eher und das wahrscheinlich sogar geplant, darauf setzt, im zweiten Jahr dann wieder voll anzugreifen, weil dann die Spieler angekommen sind, weil du dann siehst nach dem Abstieg, wo müssen wir tatsächlich nochmal nachrüsten. Das kannst du nach dem Abstieg nicht genau wissen, weil du so viel veränderst. Dementsprechend glaube ich, macht sich auch da Kiel ruhiges Umfeld. Keiner wird sich da Gedanken machen. Ich halte Marcel Rapp für einen echt guten Trainer, einer der besseren der zweiten Liga, hat sie schon mal hochgeführt. Ich mache mir um Kiel gar keine Sorgen. Ich glaube aber, dass es dieses Jahr noch nicht reichen wird. Aber Thomas, sag gerne, wenn du es anders siehst.
Grundsätzlich würde ich da mitgehen, absolut mitgehen. Das sehe ich ganz genau so. Ich würde aber auch sagen, wenn man mal drauf guckt auf den Start und auch auf die letzten vier Spiele, ich habe das jetzt gerade mal offen hier. Man sieht die ersten vier Spiele und jetzt die vier Spiele danach. Man überlegt, die haben auf Schalke, also auf Schalke, gewonnen, zu Hause in den KSC geschlagen, und dann in Elbersberg in der Nachspielzeit verloren. Und jetzt zu Hause gegen ein sehr gutes Darmstadt 1-1 geholt. Die haben in den letzten vier Spielen gerade mal zwei Gegentore bekommen und haben gegen Mannschaften allesamt aus der oberen Tabellenhälfte sieben Punkte geholt. Das ist mehr als passabel, wenn man bedenkt, wie sie gestartet sind. Und ich glaube schon, wenn Kiel jetzt auch dann so jetzt die Gegner kommen, wenn man jetzt immer die nächsten Spiele sieht, die nächsten Gegner heißen Nürnberg, Bochum, Münster, Düsseldorf. Das sind alles Mannschaften. Da traue ich Kiel absolut zu, die Spiele zu gewinnen. Und mal gucken, wie wir dann reden, wenn die jetzt wirklich in den nächsten vier Spielen 12 Punkte holen, dann sind die auf jeden Fall richtig fett oben dabei. Und auch da muss man sagen, und das ist ja was, was da auffällt, dass Rab eben scheinbar auch Dinge angepasst hat. Weil, wenn man die Gegentore sieht, die man jetzt in den letzten Spielen kassiert hat, scheint er ja auch selber oder er mit der Mannschaft gemeinsam auch gelernt zu haben und gesehen zu haben, okay, müssten sie vielleicht an der ein oder anderen Kleinigkeit was ändern. Und das sieht man jetzt. Wie Anna schon gesagt hat gegen Darmstadt, das war ein richtig gutes Spiel von Kiel. Nur sie haben halt das Pech gehabt, dass in Darmstadt mit Lidberg wahrscheinlich einer der drei besten Stürmer in dieser Liga rumläuft und dann eben aus einer Szene, die eigentlich tot ist, dann noch so ein geiles Tor erzählt. Wobei man sagen muss, das Tor von Kiel war nicht minderschön. Und da sieht man eben auch, und das ist so das, was ich immer schön finde, wenn Mannschaft und Kiel zeigt das. Wenn man Mannschaften hat, die auch Fußball einfach aussehen lassen. Wenn man sich das Tor anguckt von Kiel, dieses 1 zu 1, das ist auf links einfach durchgespielt. Der Spieler geht runter zur Grundlinie, spielt den Ball in den Rücken der Abwehr. Das ist unheimlich schwer zu verteidigen. Der Stürmer kann mit Tempo, mit Wucht in den Ball reingehen und kann sich mehr oder weniger die Ecke aussuchen. Das ist auch etwas, was Kiel gut beherrscht. Sie lassen den Fußball, den sie spielen, relativ einfach aussehen und machen da keine taktischen große Rundenbrunnen-Gehabe, sondern spielen einen zum Kader gut passenden Fußball. Ich glaube tatsächlich, wenn Kiel im Winter auf der Stürmer-Position nachlegen kann und sich da vielleicht noch jemanden holt, der dir diese 8-12 Gegentore in der Rückrunde vielleicht auch dann bringt, glaube ich tatsächlich, dass die auch eine Mannschaft sind, die durchaus länger oben mit dabei sein können. Ob es am Ende für den großen Wurf reichen wird, wird sich zeigen. Aber ich denke auch, die haben da auch eine klare Idee. Und da wird man auf jeden Fall nächstes Jahr oder also kommende Saison auf jeden Fall eine Kieler Mannschaft sehen, die wieder oben mitspielt. Wenn sie nicht sogar diese Saison schon für eine große Überraschung sorgen könnten.
Das Potenzial sehe ich definitiv auch. Lass mal so Terkelsen und auch Magnus Knudsen und so im Mittelfeld richtig ankommen. Robert Wagner haben sie sich ja auch einen sehr talentierten Spieler aus Freiburg geliehen. Lass die mal ankommen. Lass Phil Harris vielleicht wirklich auch zünden. Also ich bin großer Phil Harris-Fan. Ich finde ihn echt gut, weil Abschlussstärke, Tiefgang trotzdem nicht klein. Ich finde, er ist eigentlich ein sehr guter Stürmertyp, moderner Stürmertyp. Lass die mal ankommen. Dann geht auch was. Das müssen teilweise einfache Fehler auch in der Abwehr. Also es liegt überhaupt nicht, ich habe das Gefühl, wenn sie Gegentore kassieren, dann ist das nie strukturbedingt, sondern nur, weil jemand pennt. Und auch das liegt vielleicht darin, dass gewisse Spieler diese Liga noch nicht komplett kennen, das Team noch nicht komplett kennen, vielleicht mal in einen Raum laufen, wo sie nicht sein sollten. Wenn sich das einspielt, dann hat Kiel definitiv auch das Potenzial für mehr in dieser Saison. Ich weiß nur nicht, wie schnell das klicken wird. Aber gebe ihnen die Möglichkeit, dass das auch schon diese Saison noch passieren wird und dann ist diese Liga auch so eng, dass bis dahin wahrscheinlich niemand enteilt sein sollte. Das kommt ja noch dazu. Also da hat man auch eine gewisse Ruhe. Wie komme ich jetzt von gewisser Ruhe auf Eintracht Braunschweig? Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist moderativ schwierig.
Hashtag, was fehlt.
Finde ich gut. Nehmen wir genau das. Da hast du jetzt natürlich ein bisschen den Hut auf, Anna. Aber ich würde sagen, wir reden vielleicht am besten über dieses Paderborn-Spiel, um dann auf die grundsätzlichen Probleme im Braunschweiger-Spiel zu kommen, um dann über die Probleme im Verein zu reden. Vielleicht ist das ein ganz guter roter Faden.
Du hast gesagt eine Stunde und 15,5.
Oder eine Stunde und 30. Wir gucken mal, wie wir Spaß haben. Aber lass uns mal bei diesem Spiel bleiben. Braunschweig verliert 1 zu 2 gegen Paderborn. Das sah lange Zeit so aus. Dann wieder nicht durch das 1 zu 1 und dann wieder doch ganz schnell. Durch den direkten Anschlusstreffer, der letztendlich die Niederlage bedeuten sollte. Es ist jetzt so, dass Braunschweig 6 Spiele ohne Sieg dasteht. Davon waren 5 Niederlagen. Zuletzt gab es 4 in Serie. Man begann ja furios mit zwei Siegen in Folge. 1 zu 0 gegen Magdeburg, Thomas erinnert sich. 3 zu 2 gegen Fürth. Wie gesagt, seitdem gibt es aber eben keine Siege mehr. Und ich konfrontiere dich vielleicht mal mit der Aussage von Heiner Backhaus nach dem Spiel, weil das vielleicht ganz gut überleitet. Ich merke schon, so leichter Rauch kommt aus deinen Ohren, aber wir kriegen das hin. Wir haben inhaltlich ein gutes Spiel gemacht, haben den Gegner vor Probleme gestellt, hatten Torchancen. Ich kann der Mannschaft in der zweiten Halbzeit keinen Vorwurf machen, wir belohnen uns nicht. Von der Leistung her wäre es nicht unverdient gewesen, hier zu gewinnen. Und nach einer Nachfrage sagt, wir haben Struktur im Spiel nicht gefehlt. So, jetzt dein Take zum Paderborn-Spiel.
Ja, okay, ja, ich erkenne diesen Ausschnitt. Wie soll ich sagen? Also, es gab tatsächlich Chancen, die nicht genutzt wurden. Und es ist so, dass für diejenigen, die die Chronologie des Spiels nicht erkennen, wir haben jetzt die vierte Niederlage in Folge eingesteckt. Das heißt, davor war es schon so ein bisschen schlechte Stimmung. Ein bisschen, wie entwickelt sich das? Wir haben viele rote Karten bekommen, oder gelb-rote Karten, eine rote Karte bekommen. Wie entwickelt sich die Mannschaft? Finden wir wieder so in diese Stimmung der ersten Spiele, die ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr positiv gewesen ist. Und mit diesen ganzen Fragen und so einem Anflug von Druck gehst du in das Spiel gegen Paderborn. Und du bist die ersten 30 Sekunden nicht in Rückstand. Dann ärgerliche und ich finde relativ sinnbildliche Szene. Wir sind im Ballbesitz. Wir sind in der Vorwärtsbewegung kurz vor Mittelkreis. Wir verlieren den Ball gegen Paderborner Spieler. Das ist ja super früh im Spiel. Also der ist so kurz vor Sprint im Tempo, aber der geht nicht mehr voll aufs Ganze. Muss er ja gar nicht. Das hat ja noch alles zu tun. Und flankt dann lange rein. Der Innenverteidiger ist irgendwie noch nicht so richtig anwesend. Kopfballtor, 1-0 Rückstand. Das ist halt der Worst Case, wirklich ein schlimmer Start. Und dann rappeln wir uns so ein bisschen. Und das ist so, dass das, was wirklich nicht fehlt, ist irgendwie Engagement oder Kampfgeist oder so, dass ich denke, ich merke schon, die Mannschaft möchte. Ich würde aber ein Fragezeichen hinter dem mit der Struktur machen, was du gerade zitiert hast, weil die fehlt mir wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr doll. Das muss ich schon wirklich sagen. Also, wir haben jetzt einen Trainer, der viel über den Kopf kommt und viel übers Herz, wie auch immer, also viel über, er formuliert viel Werte, viel spricht viel von Mut, von Kampfgeist, von nicht hängen lassen, von, ne, auch von Männer sein natürlich und so dieses ganze, dieses Segment natürlich.
Am Ende steigt der männlichste auf das Wissen.
Am Ende steigt der männlichste auf, genau. Und ich habe im Moment ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Bemühungen über Strukturen verloren gehen, über den Bemühungen zu zeigen, dass man engagiert ist. Und dass das aber eher in Hektik kippt. Und dass das eher in komplett absurde, lange Bälle, so von kurz hinter der Mittellinie, so Chip-Flanken in den Strafraum von Spielern, bei denen ich denke, du kannst das doch besser. Was ist denn deine Idee dahinter? Und deswegen muss ich sagen, habe ich mich über die Aussage vom Trainer geärgert. Weil ich es mag, wenn ein Trainer nach solchen Spielen auch öffentlich sagt, das war nicht gut. Weil ich das auch nicht schlimm finde. Ich finde nicht, dass der Trainer damit irgendwerem in den Rücken fällt oder sich angreifbar macht oder die Mannschaft nicht in Schutz nimmt oder so. Sondern eher im Gegenteil. Ich würde eher sagen, er nimmt Verantwortung auf sich und ja, genau, frag mich. Ja, genau, also was das soll, ich kann es dir nicht sagen.
Also ich war natürlich nicht sauer oder angefasst, weil auch da die emotionalen Vermittlungen nach Braunschweig sind gering. Aber ich war irritiert von diesen Aussagen, weil ich eben auch überhaupt nicht fand, dass das inhaltlich ein gutes Spiel war. Es war von den Werten her ein gutes Spiel, also die du betont hast. Braunschweig wollte, es gab auch eine Phase rund um das 1 zu 1, in der man gespürt hat, mit der Einwechslung von Lino Tempelmann, geben Dinge. Aber es ist halt auch lustig, vor einer Buckhouse hörte ich mir Benjamin Kessel an, den Geschäftsführer Sport, der sagte, er hat die Abläufe vermisst. Also damit auch sehr konterkariert, was sein Trainer dann sagen sollte. Und das leitet vielleicht ja diese Niederlage, die in meinen Augen letztendlich verdient war, weil Braunschweig insgesamt– ich finde, dass innerlich eben nicht bessere Team war. Es war sicherlich eng, aber Paderborn konnte von dieser frühen Führung profitieren und hat dann sein Ding gemacht und war die reifere, besser angelegte Mannschaft, wie ich finde. Auch wenn sie dann profitieren, dass am Ende Braunschweig so ein bisschen der Kopf verloren geht nach dem 1 zu 1. Aber Grund um erst mal eine Niederlage, die okay ist. Und die leitet ja dazu über, zu den Dingen, die du auch schon erwähnt hast. Ich für meinen Teil von außen erkenne eben keine Spielidee, denn Intensität allein ist keine Spielidee. Und es gab einen sehr interessanten, sehr ausführlichen Artikel vom NDR. Der NDR bringt da ja immer mal wieder für die Vereine der Region so Datenstücke, Artikel raus, die sehr datenbasiert sind. Und dort haben sie mit einem Datenanbieter zusammengearbeitet, der mal diesen Jagdfußball, den Heiner Backhaus spielen lassen möchte, unter die Lupe genommen hat und geguckt hat, naja, ist das denn Jagdfußball? Also besteht der Fußball, den man bislang sieht, wirklich aus intensivem Anlaufen und hohem Pressing, vertikal mit direktem Offensivspiel, hohe Intensität und Zweikampfstärke, Umschaltspiel, aber auch ja Momente für Dribblings. So, das kann man ja unter Jagdfußball erst mal so verstehen. Und ich will die Leute hier jetzt nicht langweilen. Fazit ist, man sieht quasi nichts davon, auch datenbedingt. Es liegt zum einen nicht daran, dass die Mannschaft nicht will. Man ist beispielsweise bei Sprints– ich muss nochmal gucken, ob es jetzt nach dem kompletten Spieltag immer noch so ist –,Aber zwischenzeitlich war man da auf Platz 2 in der Liga. Es kann nicht so viel schlechter geworden sein, seit den Sonntagsspielen. Intensive Läufe, Lauf, Distanz, da ist man mindestens mal in der oberen Tabellenhälfte. Also die Mannschaft läuft, kämpft und das war, glaube ich, auch das Faustfahren der ersten beiden Spiele, dass du dir einfach niedergerungen hast, die Mannschaften. Aber die Spielidee mit Ball ist in meinen Augen bislang nicht vorhanden. Und ich sehe keine Struktur, ich sehe lange Bälle und die Hoffnung, dass sie irgendjemand festmacht. Dabei hast du gar nicht unbedingt auch den Spieler, der die festmacht, sondern du hast Spieler, die du eigentlich flach tief schicken möchtest. Also ein Jadimsi beispielsweise oder ein Conté. Die willst du ja nicht hoch anspielen. Das ist ja Quatsch. Du willst sie ja tief schicken und da haben die ihre Stärken. Und das haben sie ja sogar in der Saison schon bewiesen. Es gab ja Spiele, wo du dachtest, oh krass, damit können die Gegner wehtun. Aber abseits dessen sehe ich persönlich sehr wenig. Es wird sehr viel in den Formationen gewechselt. Also keine Formationen, hat der Datenanbieter auch herausgekehrt, wurde länger als ein Viertel der Saison bislang gespielt. Bei acht Spielen nicht viel. Also keine Formation, hat zwei Spiele überlebt. Und das verunsichert diese Mannschaft zusätzlich, hat man das Gefühl. Und dadurch geht irgendwann ja auch eine gewisse Intensität im Spiel verloren. Also die Mannschaft fängt extrem intensiv an und lässt irgendwann in den Laufwerten und so weiter extrem nach. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das daran liegt, dass die Mannschaft aus der Puste ist, sondern meine tiefste Überzeugung– ich habe jetzt auch ein paar Fußballspieler im Leben geguckt– ist, kaum eine Mannschaft läuft wenig, weil sie faul ist. Sondern Mannschaften laufen viel, weil sie von der Idee überzeugt sind und nicht groß nachdenken müssen. Wenn sie ins Nachdenken kommen, bleiben sie stehen. Das sieht man bei Hertha auch immer wieder. Aber sobald sie laufen– und Hertha hat jetzt gegen Münster 127 Kilometer abgespielt, das sind 12 Kilometer mehr als bislang im Schnitt. Die sind quasi einspieler-mehr gelaufen. Oh Wunder, funktionieren Dinge. So, und bei Braunschweig, die fangen motiviert an, merken dann irgendwann, ja scheiße, unser Trainer hat wieder vergessen, uns die Werkzeuge in den Werkzeugkasten zu legen. Was machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Und hören auf zu laufen. Und das ist ein einigermaßen desolates Bild, wenn man das auf eine ganze Saison zieht. Weil mir– hilft mir da, Anna– fehlt so ein bisschen die Fantasie dafür, wie will denn Braunschweig ein Fußballspiel gewinnen?
Ja, ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also die ersten– wir hatten ja das erste Spiel gegen Magdeburg, dass wir in Unterzahl sogar 1-0 gewinnen konnten.
Imponierender Auftritt.
Durch so ein Traumtor von dem Schalker Neuzugang. Aydin. Super Typ, wirklich. Also wirklich so ein Zehner-Typ, so wuselig, enger Wendekreis, gut am Ball, so viel Intuition. Und dann haben wir gegen Fürth gespielt. Das war halt, ne, erst das Heimspiel spät, das 3-2 gemacht, aufregendes Spiel hieß das und so. Und dann kam ja dieses monumentale Spiel gegen den VfB Stuttgart, dieses Pokalspiel unter der Woche. Wir hatten eine englische Woche, weil ja Stuttgart Pokalsieger geworden ist und durch den Supercup am Pokalsamstagabend spielen dann Meister und Pokalsieger unter der Woche. Natürlich gibt es legendäre Pokalabende in Braunschweig. Marc, du erinnerst dich an die, ich glaube, es war irgendwie 9 zu 9 oder so.
Nee, da klingelt gar nichts. Also immer souverän in Braunschweig weitergekommen.
Ja, ich fand es total toll, dieses Spiel. Und ich kenne keinen, dem das anders geht, gar nicht so sehr wegen, wir sind ja dann am Ende auch ausgeschieden, also wir hatten ja gar nichts davon. Aber wir waren im Mai in der Relagation im Free-TV und wir sind nicht so oft auf diesen großen Bühnen. Und dann siehst du irgendwie deinen Verein vor der Free-TV, vor dem Free-TV-Publikum wirklich einfach um seine Existenz kämpfen und gerade so noch den Arsch durch die Tür kriegen. Und ein paar Monate später ist es dann eins der besten, also eins der besten Pokal-Erstrundenspiele, die wahrscheinlich jemals gespielt worden sind. Zumindest, und er muss es wissen, hat Basti Schweinsteiger gesagt, als Kommentator hat er sowas wirklich rar gesehen live. Und das hat irgendwie, das hat uns alle irgendwie gut fühlen lassen. Und das beantwortet alles nicht deine Frage, weil ich sie auch gar nicht beantworten kann. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie wir jemals ein Spiel gewinnen sollen. Der Kader ist gar nicht so schlecht, aber er macht ja nichts aus dem, was er tun sollte, nämlich Fußball spielen. Und dann kam es nach der Englischen Woche zu einem Ligaspiel gegen Arminia Bielefeld. Und es lief eigentlich alles sogar ganz gut. Wir lagen eins, neun in Führung. Und Anfang der zweiten Halbzeit hat sich unser Innenverteidiger Frank-Hart verletzt, Neuzugang von Preußen Münster. Und ich fand es total cool, dass wir den gewinnen konnten. Innenverteidiger super, weil Armin Bitacic war gegangen, Säule in der Mannschaft fehlte, Innenverteidigung mit Zweitliga, Abstiegskamferfahrung top. So, der verletzt sich. Und wir haben vor seiner Verletzung in der Liga vier Gegentore rufgefangen. Und in der gleichen Anzahl der Spiele, nach seiner Verletzung zwölf. So. Also irgendwie stimmt da was nicht so richtig. In der Defensive natürlich auch gefördert durch gelb-rote Karten und eine rote Karte. Dazu muss ich sagen, die Statistik ist halt übel. Wir haben, glaube ich, wir haben drei gelb-rote Karten, eine rote Karte in sechs Liga-Spielen bekommen. Wir sind aber jetzt keine– da ist niemand kaputt gegangen beim Gegner. Das war schlechtes Timing. Das war Leichtsinnigkeit und es war halt– und das kreide ich halt einfach so dieser darüberstehenden Jagdfußball-Tirade an. Dieses, ich muss was machen. Ich muss was machen. Im Zweifel mache ich es falsch.
Also die überdrehen.
Genau. Und es ist ja total gut, dass du keine Angst davor hast, Fehler zu machen. Aber es ist schlecht, wenn du so sehr Aktionen haben möchtest, dass du im Zweifel einen Fehler machst, als dir Zeit zu lassen. Und ich sehe halt viel Voreile im Spiel. Ich sehe viel Hektik. Ich sehe viel Sprints, aber viel unproduktive Sprints. Ich sehe auch Sprints, die nicht synchron gehen mit der Gesamtlaufleistung, die meistens schlechter ist als beim Gegner. Also heiße Luft, so ein bisschen. Und mit all due respect passt auch dieser Begriff irgendwie ganz gut zum Trainer.
Perfekte Überleitung, denn für uns mal gerne ein… Man hat ja nun… Ich erinnere mich, welcher Spieler war das? War das Sven Köler? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Nach der Redigration hat ein Braunschweig-Spieler mal richtig ausgepackt und gesagt, das ist hier alles kacke. Wir müssten eigentlich alles abreißen. Die Methodiken, alles ist veraltet in diesem Verein. War das Sven Köler?
Ja.
Der, glaube ich, generell durchaus ein… Also nicht ohne Grund Kapitän, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, genau.
Klarer Worte.
Ja, ja, definitiv.
Und dann entschied man sich dafür, Heiner Backhaus zu holen, der erst 43 ist. Also schon… Und ja, offensichtlich ein neues Zweitliga-Gesicht. Der Mann hat sich hochgearbeitet. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Also der war Trainer bei Inter Leipzig, Reden, Sonnenhof, Groß Asbach, Koblenz, BFC Dynamo, Aachen und ist jetzt bei Braunschweig angekommen. Nun muss man sagen, dass Heiner Backhaus trotzdem jemand ist, der schon viel Geschichte mitbringt, weil er hat gefühlt bei jedem Verein bislang heiße Luft, äh heiße Luft, nee, verbrannte Erde, andere Feuermetapher, auch heiß. Auch heiß. Alles ist heiß. Heißt ja auch Backhaus mit Nachnamen.
Ja.
Es schließt sich in den Kreis. Das ist alles sehr... Er gibt alles Sinn. Aber welchen Eindruck hat er gemacht zum... Also, wie wurde er aufgenommen? Wie hat er sich zu Beginn präsentiert? Und wie hat sich das Bild vielleicht schon nach 8 Spielen gefestigt, gewandelt? Führe uns da gerne mal ein.
Ich glaube, bei vielen kam der total gut an am Anfang. Weil der ist so ein super Rhetoriker. Und ich glaube, gerade nach diesem schrecklichen Mai und die Relegationsspiele waren wirklich schlimm. Es ist wirklich schrecklich gewesen, in die Verlängerung gehen zu müssen gegen Saarbrücken zu Hause, nachdem die aus dem Nichts doch noch zwei Tore machen. Und du hängst da halb in der dritten Liga drin und du denkst, fuck, das war es dann halt auch wahrscheinlich. Weil keine Ahnung, wie wir das noch heilen sollen. Und du brauchst dann schon jemanden, der da irgendwie einen Fuß in diese Krisentür bekommt. Entweder ein weicher Typ, der das irgendwie so ein bisschen väterlich macht. Und Buckhaus ist halt eher der, ja, so, ne, wir machen das jetzt neu und es wird super. Und wir stehen jetzt zusammen und als Team und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gab es sehr natürlich zwei Lager in Braunschweig, nämlich diejenigen, die das alles so ein bisschen fischy fanden, den Abgang aus Aachen, weil der da ja große, treue Schwüre geleistet hat. Sogar auf seinen toten Vater gesagt hat, er verlässt den Verein nicht.
Und Ähnliches, vielleicht nicht auf den toten Vater, hat er halt auch schon beim BFC Dynamo abgezogen, um dann zu Aachen zu gehen.
Und ich finde, es ist so ein bisschen– ich verstehe, wenn Leute dieses Seifentheater auch ein bisschen mitspielen wollen, weil natürlich willst du gemocht werden und keine Ahnung. Ich wohne in Hannover, da sagen immer alle Trainer, oh, die Stadt ist so grün. Ja, okay. Und ich dachte aber, ja, okay, was ist ja irgendwie was anderes, als das, was er da offenbar irgendwie von sich gegeben hat an Zuneigungsbekundungen. Und ich fand es ein bisschen auch so die Reaktion bei Social Media. Klar, gibt es dann irgendwie Hass vom abgebenden Verein. Aber da waren auch wirklich sachliche Stimmen dabei, die gesagt haben, boah, irgendwie, das war echt nicht okay, was der hier gemacht hat. Und es gab halt im Braunschweig Leute, die gesagt haben, boah, irgendwie traue ich dem Typen nicht. Und andere, die gesagt haben, ja, das ist das Geschäft. Leg mal irgendwie hier deine Mentalität ab, deine Leichtgläubigkeit. Man muss das Spiel eben mitspielen. Wir profitieren doch auch davon, wenn wir irgendwo Last-Minute-Spieler ablösen können, blablabla. Und was ich ganz spannend finde, ist, dass ich den Eindruck habe, zumindest, wenn ich die Kommentare bei Instagram sehe und inzwischen auch bei YouTube. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ihr das beobachtet. Ich finde, bei YouTube ist die Kommentarspalte schon noch mal ein bisschen tougher. Aber auf beiden Plattformen sagen die Leute, was ist denn jetzt deine Idee, bis auf Kampf und so? Weil irgendwie, also es funktioniert ja nicht. Und das ist ja okay, dass es nicht funktioniert. Wir müssen ja rausfinden, was funktioniert. Aber um rausfinden zu können, was funktioniert, müsste man halt irgendwie was verändern. Und wenn er was verändert, über personelle Maßnahmen hinweg, dann sehe ich das irgendwie nicht so richtig. Also ja, und das macht mich wirklich ratlos und auch so ein bisschen betroffen, weil da natürlich auch Benny Kessel dranhängt, also unser Sportdirektor, der immerhin ihm auch 100.000 Euro für den Trainer ausgegeben hat. Was ich viel finde für einen Drittliga-Trainer und eine Zweitliga-Erfahrung, weil der Kader besser ist. Also wir konnten jetzt auch mit Yadimchi und– jetzt muss ich den Namen einmal nachgucken– eine Leitgabe aus Leipzig, die leider noch nicht gespielt hat. Ne, tatsächlich auch im Sturm. Ach, der. Robert Ramsack. So ganz vielversprechend unseren schmerzhaftesten Abgang, nämlich Rayon Philippe, Richtung HSV kompensieren. Und ich traue dem Kader wirklich mehr zu, als das, was letzte Saison in Braunschweig stattgefunden hat. Und es ist bedauerlich, dass davon so wenig zu sehen ist. Hängt vielleicht auch mit der frühen und langen Verletzung von Lino Tempelmann zusammen. Das ist natürlich krass, was da passiert ist. Auch da zum Hintergrund die Chronologie ist, man konnte Ron-Thomas Hoffmann von Schalke wieder los eisen, der ja dorthin abgewandert war, kurzzeitig dann wieder zurückgegangen ist. Und von Ron-Thomas Hoffmann, der im Tor steht, ging halt wirklich maßgeblich der Transfer von Lino Tempelmann auch aus Schalke zur Braunschweigereintracht zurück. Das heißt, der hat da wirklich effektiv Fäden gezogen. Und es wäre schade, wenn diese Bemühungen ins Leere laufen.
Er hat jetzt ja gegen Paderborn gespielt, Lino Tempelmann. Es ging ja auch nochmal merklichen Ruck durch die Mannschaft. Es ist ja schon jemand, der spielerisch wie emotional dieser Mannschaft viel gibt. Das hat man ja auch in der Rückrunde gespürt. Da ging ja gefühlt alles über ihn und seine Distanztore. Generell der Dreierpark aus Schalke, Hoffmann, Tempelmann, Aydin, der hat gesessen. Ich finde generell die Transfer-Sommer, der ist nicht so schlecht. Ich bin großer Fan von Robin Häusler. Ich verstehe nicht, warum der beim KSC nicht funktioniert hat, weil ich den in Wiesbaden richtig gut fand. Aber ich finde den gut. Frenkert hast du schon angesprochen, ordentlicher Innenverteidiger. Du hast den Kader verjüngt. Klar, Rayan Philipp, das tut weh, aber ich finde, dass du mit Jadim Schi eigentlich eine gute Antwort gefunden hast, vom Profil her. Aber Thomas, um dich mal kurz in die Szene zurückzuholen, du hast ja nun am ersten Spieltag die wuchtige Braunschweige Eintracht erlebt. Was war denn das für ein Spiel und wie blickst du dann mit den weiteren Spielen dann auf die Herangehensweise von Heiner Backhaus? Gerade hört man dich nicht. Jetzt hört man dich.
So, jetzt müsste sie mich hören. Richtig. Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie jeder das sieht, aber das erste Spiel, ich glaube, da kam Braunschweig zu drei Punkten, wie die Jungfrau zum Kind. Also das war ja ein Spiel auf ein Tor und dann schießen die da einmal aus Tor und unter gütiger Mithilfe unseres Abwehrspielers und unseres Torhüters geht der Ball dann rein. Ja, und ansonsten hat man, also ich finde, man hat da schon gesehen, spielerisch ist von Braunschweig, ich weiß nicht, ob es am Trainer liegt oder grundsätzlich, aber spielerisch von Braunschweig glaube ich nicht viel zu erwarten. Also ich fand das nicht gut gegen uns, auch wenn sie dann am Ende drei Punkte geholt haben, das ist entscheidend am Ende. Aber das war kein gutes Spiel von Braunschweig. Natürlich auch die Tatsache, die rote Karte, die dazu kam. Da wurde natürlich klar, dass man dann noch mehr sich auf die Defensive konzentriert. Das ist auch völlig in Ordnung. Aber ich fand das Spiel damals schon von Braunschweig nicht so stark. In Viert kann ich nichts zu sagen, das Spiel habe ich nicht gesehen. Aber was man jetzt bei Eintracht sieht, das wirkt alles noch nicht so gefestigt. Auch innerhalb greift einfach nicht, habe ich das Gefühl. Man hat den Eindruck, dass der Eintrachter das Spiel noch ein bisschen falsch geltet. Aber offensiv wirkt das auch ein bisschen zufällig. Man hat es gesehen, die Paterbornen haben mit relativ einfachen Mitteln geschafft, Braunschweig immer wieder vom Tor wegzuhalten und kaum etwas zugelassen. Obwohl man da gar nicht viel investieren musste, hatte ich den Eindruck auf Paterborner Seite. Buckhaus scheint so ein Trainer zu sein, der– Anna hat es auch gesagt– viel über Emotionen kommt. Ich glaube, wenn das irgendwann mal vorbei ist, dann wird es schwierig, wenn du keinen klaren Spielplan hast. Man ist es nicht mehr zu erkennen, dass man sagt, wir versuchen, defensiv grundsätzlich gut zu stehen und dann über einen klaren Umschaltfußball und über starke Standardsituationen zum Erfolg zu kommen. So ein bisschen sieht man in Braunschweig noch nicht so ein Konzept. Die Frage ist, wie lange geht das gut? Klar, man hat am Anfang jetzt sieben Punkte geholt in den ersten drei Spielen. Aber jetzt inzwischen sieht man ja schon, dass da eine Mannschaft an ihre Grenzen kommt. Und es ist wirklich interessant zu sehen, woran liegen die Grenzen? Liegt es am Trainer oder liegt es am Kader? Und das ist jetzt wirklich, glaube ich, auch eine Frage, die sich da stellen, die man sich langsam in Braunschweig stellen muss. Und ich finde die Aussage von Benjamin Kessel, glaube ich, heißt er. Ich hoffe, ich habe dir jetzt keinen Mist erzählt. Da muss man schon sagen, das ist schon vielsand, wenn dann ein Sportdirektor sich hinstellt oder ein Sportchef sich hinstellt und nach dem Spiel dann so eine Aussage trifft, finde ich schon krass. Und das scheint jedoch zu zeigen, dass man scheinbar jetzt mit der spielerischen Entwicklung in Braunschweig auf oberer Etage nicht ganz so zufrieden ist, um es mal ein bisschen vorsichtig auszudrücken.
Ich fand das Interview von Benjamin Kessel aber wirklich gut von außen, weil das war gerechtfertigt kritisch, das war angenehm ehrlich, das war also ohne unsachlich zu werden oder so. Aber ich finde, ohne es direkt sagen zu müssen, zählt er den Trainer eben doch an. Also er spricht klar davon, dass in der Länderspielpause der Reset-Knopf gefunden werden muss. Das heißt eben auch, man geht mit einer Bacchus in diese Länderspielpause, aber wenn es dann die ersten ein, zwei Spiele danach keine Verbesserung gibt, dann wird man auch nicht zögern. Und ich finde, das spricht aber auch für einen Leistungsgedanken, der erstmal ja gut ist, dass man das auch zugeben könnte. Ja, okay, wir haben aufs falsche Pferd gesetzt. Das sah in Aachen bei dem gut aus, wir wollten Ähnliches hier merken auf Zweitliganiveau, funktioniert das reine Anzünden von Spielern vielleicht nicht so gut. Das ist ja eine Erkenntnis. Und jetzt hat man halt auch wirklich das Krisen-Duell, doch ist schon so, dann gegen Düsseldorf. Das wird ja schon spannend. Und ich meine, Anna, wir können jetzt auch einen Riesenpunkt aufmachen, dieses herumgeeiere generell von Eintracht, was du ja auch schon öfter in diesem Podcast hier beschrieben hast. Ich habe mal nachgeguckt, ich konnte es kaum fassen. Man ist also seit 2018, es ist ein ständiges herumgeeiert zwischen Dritt und Zweiter Liga. Man hat fünf komplette Zweitligasaisons seitdem gespielt. Platzierungen in der zweiten Liga sind 17, 17, 15, 15, 16 und aktuell 15. Das ist ja irre. Ja, absolut. Vielleicht auch da, um das zurückzuholen, was Sven Köhler gesagt hat, dass eigentlich alles in diesem Verein general überholt werden müsste. Und verbunden mit einem Benjamin Kessler, der ja noch eigentlich, also klar, alter Braunschweiger, aber in dieser Funktion ja ein unverbrauchtes Gesicht ist, hast du denn das Gefühl, jetzt mal abseits von der aktuellen sportlichen Situation, dass man in Braunschweig verstanden hat, dass man jetzt auch mal wieder Schritte nach vorne gehen muss und Vision haben muss. Oder fühlt sich das doch insgesamt immer noch ja Bleyern und Altbacken an?
Ich glaube, die Bemühungen sind absolut da. Also zum Beispiel auch eben deshalb bei mir die große Hoffnung, die ich in Ron Tom Hoffmann gesetzt habe, dass er einfach jemand sein kann, der mannschaftsintern nach innen und außen dafür sorgt, dass wir so ein bisschen ablegen, ein Verein zu sein, der in der 2. Liga besteht, weil er so die alten Spieler aufträgt. So. Sondern junge Spieler holt und holen kann, die vielleicht sogar woanders hingegangen werden, aber die einfach Bock haben, irgendwie sich in dem Team für ein paar Jahre zu entwickeln oder so. Und das war halt einfach das Kriterium, dass die Eintracht erfolgreich gemacht hat in ihren erfolgreichen Jahren. Und das glaube ich auch im Moment der ausschlaggebende Punkt, warum leihen Bundesligisten Top-Talente nach Elbersberg aus, weil sie wissen, dass es da funktioniert. Warum leihen Freiburg-Spieler nach Kiel aus, weil sie wissen, dass es da funktioniert. Und ich glaube, du musst einfach dringend rauskommen aus diesem, aus dem Grappeltischbereich. Und ich hatte im Sommer eigentlich das Gefühl, dass das funktioniert. Und wie gesagt, ich bleibe auch dabei. Ich finde den Kader, vielleicht hast du halt nicht, du hast halt nicht diesen Philipp, du hast nicht diesen Stern, obwohl er unter diesem Dasein für mein Empfinden jetzt auch nicht immer top performt hat. Er ist ein junger Typ so und da irgendwie immer das Wohl und Wehe auf den eigenen Schultern zu spüren und tragen zu müssen, ist sicherlich irgendwie auch nicht cool. Ja, aber das ist halt so ein bisschen die Frage, dieses Steilgeruch-Thema, dass er Vereine immer wieder irgendwie beschäftigt. Wie viel braucht man da? Was ist die richtige Dose?
Da sind wir wieder bei den Pferden.
Ja, genau. Was ist die richtige Dose Steilgeruch? Weil Benny Kessey kommt, oder er hat in Braunschweig lang gespielt, ist dann wieder zurückgekommen, Rettungsaktionen, dies, das und so. Und jetzt ist er da sehr aktiv mit Marc Pfitznern, der ist Co-Trainer geblieben, über die Trainer hinweg. Und ich glaube, du musst halt schon aufpassen, dass du nicht in Richtung Klüngel kippst.
Jaja, voll. Auch das kennt man bei der Hertha aus Berlin sehr gut. Es ist ein schmaler Grad, definitiv.
Ja, und dann denke ich auch, ja, Klüngeln, warum so? Also könnt ihr euch mal irgendwie raffen und einordnen. Wir sind irgendwie ein ganz okayer, hoffentlich beständiger Zweitligist in einer sehr durchschnittlichen Stadt. Also kann man sich da irgendwie mal ein bisschen irgendwie reflektieren, dass man echt nicht die geilste Adresse ist und dass man das irgendwie kompensieren muss. Also, und das ist ja völlig okay. So ich liebe Braunschweig, ich liebe den Verein und alles super. Aber das ist einfach nicht the place to be in der ganzen Republik. Es ist eben so. So in Kiel hast du wenigstens das Meer. In Freiburg kannst du gut Fahrrad fahren, da scheint immer die Sonne.
Was ist denn die Attraktion in Braunschweig? Gibt es eine Braunschweig-Attraktion? Touristenattraktion? Weiß das gar nicht. Ich war noch nie in Braunschweig.
Ja, dann wird es aber Zeit auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, dass du darüber schon kommen kannst. Da hat Backhaus schon einen Punkt. Die Braunschweiger stehen hinter jedem Sportverein, der da performt. Die stehen hinter den Basketballlöwen. Die füllen auch beim Handball-Endspiel in der 3. Liga. Da ist die Halle voll. Wir gehen dahin, Tabellenkeller, gerade Relegationen durchgekämpft, Stadion 21.000 Leute. Und deswegen nervt es mich so– und jetzt schweife ich hier doch ein bisschen ab und es wird ein bisschen emotionaler –,Dass sich da dann jemand hinstellt und sagt, er würde sich so ein bisschen stören an der negativen Grundhaltung der Braunschweiger. Und ich denke so, willst du mich verarschen?
Warum seid ihr denn so gestresst, Anna?
Ja, hast du dir mal irgendwie angeguckt, was hier die letzten Jahre passiert ist?
Lächeln doch mal.
Du hast negativer Fächtung. Wir haben noch ein paar Tore geschossen seit dem Sommer. Ja, aber die Wunden sind echt tief. Und ich kenne einige, die jetzt drohen in so einer Fußballdepression, ohne psychische Krankheiten beschönigen zu wollen, aber die einfach wirklich abstumpfen. Die das nicht mehr fühlen. Die das auch nicht mehr schrecklich finden. Und da muss der Verein irgendwie wirklich dringend, dringend, dringend was tun. Deswegen kann ich schon nachvollziehen, warum man Buckhausen eine gute Besetzung fand, um diesen ganzen Brei wieder ein bisschen zu lösen. Aber dafür braucht er dann doch in dieser spröden Kämpferansprache ein bisschen mehr Feingefühl dafür, dass wir hier echt in der Scheiße stecken. Also, naja.
Ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, auf der Note sollten wir es beenden. Manchmal ist so eine Kampfansage zum Ende genau das Richtige. Und wir haben ja auch noch einen Verein. Und da hole ich dann auch Thomas wieder mehr rein. Ist ja auch unfair, jetzt einfach zu sagen, Dresden, weil es im Osten ist, kann es ja auch. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es doch ein bisschen näher als andere Vereine. Seien wir ehrlich. Wir reden jetzt über Dynamo Dresden. Die stehen nämlich immer noch hinter Eintracht Braunschweig. Das ist doch schon mal was. Und das, ja, ich glaube, 4 Punkte? Nee, ne, stimmt gar nicht. 1 Punkt. Dresden hat 6 Punkte. So wird ein Shoot raus. Dynamo Dresden, das wissen wir alle. So viel haben wir mitbekommen, ist zurück in der zweiten Liga. Das ist natürlich ein Gewinn für diese Liga, diesen wuchtigen Traditionsverein zurückgewonnen zu haben. Doch wie ist Dresden überhaupt gestartet? Nun ja, mindestens mal durchwachsen. Erst ein Sieg in 8 Spielen, seit 5 Spielen kein Sieg mehr. Das größte Problem, ich nehme es vorweg, ist wohl die Abwehr, würde ich behaupten. Man hat noch kein Spiel zu Null gespielt, man hat 16 Gegentore. Das war vorm Spieltag die schwächste Abwehr. Nee, das war zwischenzeitlich an diesem Spieltag die schwächste Abwehr. Ich weiß nicht, ob heute jemand so viel kassiert hat, dass sich das geändert hat. Ich gucke live nach. Ah, guck mal, ja siehst du. Ja stimmt, Magdeburg 19, ja. Und Fürth 18. Es ist die drittschlechteste Abwehr. Das hat sich ein bisschen verbessert, ist trotzdem Alarmsignal. Thomas, was für ein Eindruck macht Dynamo Dresden bislang auf dich? Wo liegen die großen Probleme? Wo muss man ansetzen?
Also für mich klassischer Aufsteiger. Also Dresden erinnert mich sehr an unsere erste Saison damals, als wir aufgestiegen sind unter Christian Tietz. Das ist für mich genau das Gleiche. Offensiv einen guten Plan, der auch in regelmäßigen Abständen funktioniert. Es ist ja schon so, Dresden ist schon in der Lage, sich Chancen rauszuspielen. Sie machen auch Tore, aber eben, was du sagst, defensiv diese Stabilität, die ist noch komplett verloren. Das ist, glaube ich, das große Problem, was Dresden hat. Ich glaube, die Spielidee, die dort herrscht, auch das Spielermaterial, was man hat, passt gut zu dieser Spielidee. Die Frage ist einfach, schafft das Dynamo Dresden, so in dieser Liga anzukommen, dass man eben am Ende diese Punkte holt. Ich würde sagen, ja. Ich finde, man ist in Dresden auf einem guten Weg. Wenn man es jetzt schafft, defensiv diese Stabilität reinzubekommen, glaube ich schon, dass das eine Mannschaft ist, die genug offensive Wucht entwickeln kann, eben Spiele auch mal 1 zu 0 oder 2 zu 1 zu gewinnen und dann eben auch drin zu bleiben. Das hat man jetzt auch gesehen gegen den KSC. Ich meine, gegen die musste erst mal drei Tore machen. Am Ende haben sie sogar ein bisschen Pech. Ich bin der Meinung, die können in der Schlussphase sogar noch 4 zu 3 gewinnen.
Seid gleichzeitig Glück, dass sie das Tor noch so kurz vor Schluss machen.
Keine Frage, aber sie haben danach sogar noch die Möglichkeit, das Spiel auch noch zu entscheiden für sich. Also von daher, ja, ich glaube schon, Dresden hat ein bisschen gebraucht. Also ich fand das erste Spiel gegen Fürth, auch wenn sie da zwei Tore geschossen haben und auch viel Ballbesitz hatten, fand ich schon, hat man gesehen, wo die Probleme einfach sind. Auch gegen uns, fand ich, hat man das gesehen. Schön, dass wir das Spiel wenigstens gewinnen konnten. Irgendwas ist schön. Ja, aber auch da hat man gesehen und da dachte ich mir so, oh, Dresden wird mal gucken. Aber die haben sich, finde ich, seitdem zumindest offensiv schon auch gesteigert, haben auch, finde ich, verdient in Bielefeld gewonnen. Wenn sie am Ende auch ein bisschen glücklich waren, natürlich mit diesem Tor des Monats, was sie da machen, auch, ja. Aber das haben sie eben in den ersten Spielen nicht gehabt und haben da auch verdient gewonnen. Und ich glaube schon, Dresden ist, finde ich, aus meiner Sicht, eigentlich grundsätzlich auf einem guten Weg, auch wenn die Ergebnis jetzt vielleicht noch nicht ganz so dafür sprechen.
Ja, ich war ja recht skeptisch, aber schon sorgenvoll in der Saisonprognose, weil ich da schon mehr oder weniger diese Überschrift hatte, nur Wucht wird nicht reichen. Und das Wort hast du jetzt auch schon genutzt, Thomas. Damit beschreibt man Dresden bislang sehr gut. Ich finde, das ist so ein Phasenteam. In manchen Minuten sehen die herausragend gut aus. Dann entwickeln die eine krasse Wucht im 4-2-2-2 oder 4-3-3, was sie jetzt spielen unter Trainer Thomas Stamm. Das stellt den Gegnern vor Probleme. Daferner, Lemmer, Fröding, das kann richtig Spaß machen. Das hat richtig Dampf. Auch, weil die auf Ausseher sehr hoch schieben. Also Risch und so. Oder auf der anderen Seite, wie heißt der Wind, den sie da geholt haben, Mosgallen. Ist ja auch egal. Das kann richtig Wucht entwickeln. Mir fehlt aber echt die Balance im Spiel. Das zeigt allein, wie schnell Dynamo sich nach eigenen Treffern direkt das Gegentor fängt. Das habe ich jetzt nicht noch mal komplett nachvollzogen, aber es war gefühlt immer so im Spiel, dass wenn sie das Tor machen, relativ schnell dann auch das Gegentor fällt, weil Euphorie weiter nach vorne. Wie machen es jetzt? Ich finde bislang recht, sich die Transferphase– ist ja nicht immer möglich, um Gottes Willen– aber man hat eigentlich keine Zweitliga-Erfahrung dazugewonnen und man hatte sie auch nicht im Kader. Es ist kein Zweitliga-Erfahrung im Kader, im Gegenteil. Dadurch fehlt Dresden so eine Coolness, so eine Ruhe, um auch mal weniger Fehler zu machen. Sie machen ja sehr viele einfache Fehler. Das ist jetzt auch gegen den KSC passiert. Also, eigener Ballverlust kurz vor dem 16er, Gegentor. Das zieht sich echt durch. Was auch Sorgen machen muss, sind die Heimspiele. Ich hätte gedacht, das ist das Faust-Hand von Dynamo Dresden diese Saison. Pustekuchen. Bislang zwei Punkte aus vier Heimspielen. Auch da vielleicht eine Druck-Thematik. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Das ist natürlich immer schnell dahergesagt. Ich habe jetzt die Spielverläufe nicht mal komplett nachvollzogen. Aber ich hätte eher gedacht, dass Dresden die Punkte zu Hause holt. Anna, was ist denn so dein Bild bislang von der SGB?
Ja, also ich finde sie wirklich sehr spielstark tatsächlich. Also ich habe sie gegen Hannover etwas konzentrierter gesehen und jetzt natürlich auch gestern in dem Spiel gegen den KSC. Das ist so ein bisschen das Komplementärstück eigentlich zu unseren Problemen, weil die halt mit dem Ball richtig super unterwegs sind und ohne Ball echt dürftig unterwegs sind. Also für Fußballliebhaber Eintracht Braunschweig gegen Dynamo Dresden, das wird ein Hit. Und mit Blick auf den Kader, finde ich, spiegelt sich das so ganz gut wieder. Du hattest eben gerade die Zweitliga-Erfahrung angesprochen, die ich in der Innenverteidigung, glaube ich, auch nicht so sehr sehe. Aber in der Offensive schon. Also mit Christoph Daferne, der ja auch regelmäßig trifft, der vom Club kam. Vincent Vermeil von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Und dann natürlich der ähnliche Wut wie Martin Warnizek, Stefan Kutschke. Also als der gestern im Fernsehen aufgetaucht ist, habe ich kurz auf die Uhr geguckt und dachte, ja krass, der spielt noch, weil der hat natürlich auch Zweitliga-Erfahrung von vorigen Ausflügen. Und das ist halt wirklich phänomenal, finde ich, dass das einfach halt funktioniert, wenn du da so einen energiegeladenen, ein Schlachtross, es ist ein Pferd.
Das Pferd.
Das habe ich getan.
Ist das gut. Der 36-jährige bürtige Dresdner. Ich habe mal geguckt, 130 Zweitligaspieler hat er immerhin auf dem Tacho.
Wahnsinn.
Hättest du, aber könntest du mir sagen, wo er die geholt hat? Ich muss noch mal gucken. Nürnberg, Dresden und Ingolstadt.
Guck mal an. Krass. Na gut, er ist 36. Ja, genau. Das funktioniert halt einfach. Und ich finde das so krass, weil ja klar, auch gerade eine Mannschaft, in der du Zweitliga-Erfahrungen noch so ein bisschen aufbauen musst, sowas einfach zur Orientierung so sehr hilft, wie so ein, so läuft das hier. Und wenn ich mal irgendwie nicht reicher weiß.
Er spielt ja auch gar nicht mehr so viel, aber er ist da.
Aber er ist da, genau. Und wenn er spielt, dann merkt man ihn halt auch. Und wenn nicht in den Aktionen, dann in der Interaktion mit dem Gegner, physischer Art oder...
Schiedsrichter.
Genau. Ja. Und das finde ich super wichtig. Und einfach smart, den zu halten. Das finde ich halt so Aspekte in der Kaderplanung, die super, super essenziell sind. Also Leuchttürme.
Das ist genau so ein Spielertyp, wie er bei uns komplett fehlt.
Ja. Total.
Genau so ein Typ, der uns halt fehlt.
Drecksau. Um anderes Tier mal zu nennen. Guck mal, die haben im Kader Alexander Rossipal.
Ja, ein Pferd.
Ja, eben. Da kann eigentlich gar nichts mehr schiefgehen an der Stelle. Das tut mir leid. Da kann mein Gehirn dann irgendwann nicht mehr loslassen von der Geschichte.
Den Witz reiten wir jetzt weiter.
So, sehr, sehr gut. Guck mal. Abschließende Worte zu Dynamo Dresden. Ich, um Gottes willen, die brauchst du nicht abschreiben. Die haben eine Wucht. Da gibt es definitiv die Kreativität, wie die Spiele gewinnen. Das ist vielleicht so, wie mir Fantasie bei Braunschweig fehlt, habe ich sie definitiv bei Dresden, wie die Spiele gewinnen wollen, um Gottes willen. Aber sie haben halt nicht mehr im Vergleich so hohe individuelle Klasse wie in der 3. Liga, sodass sie einfach dieses wir schießen halten Tor mehr als der Gegner spielweise einfach so durchziehen können. Und da erwarte ich mir auch von Thomas Stamm, den Trainer, den ich für einen fähigen Trainer halte und nicht ohne Grund hat der Dresden hochgeführt. Da wird es irgendwann eine weitere Dimension brauchen im Spiel. Und nicht nur Wucht, nicht nur Flanken. Das ist ja die flankenintensivste Mannschaft der 2. Liga. Die Cup wollen da alles reinschädeln. Und das kann auch in der 2. Liga wunderbar funktionieren. Da gibt es genug Beispiele. Schalke schafft es gerade auch ohne eine wirkliche Spielanlage, Tabellen zweiter zu sein, völlig irre. Und die sehen mitbei definitiv schlechter aus als Dresden. Aber sie sind defensiv gut. Und Dresden muss dahingehend echt was machen. Vielleicht fällt auch da im Winter ja der ein oder andere Spieler runter, dass sie sich da vielleicht nochmal was zusammenleihen können. Bis dahin gilt es, den Anschluss zu halten. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Programm jetzt aussieht. Ich rufe es de facto jetzt auf. Ja, ich meine, Münster-Paderborn-Hertha ist jetzt auch nicht leicht. Immerhin zwei Auswärtsspiele dabei. Wie gesagt, zu Hause sieht es ja aktuell nicht so gut aus. Aber es sind jetzt auch nicht die Spiele, wo man sagt, jo, da, die Kehrtwende, gar kein Problem. Wobei sie, Hertha, also Berlin, werden sie einnehmen. Ich erinnere mich an ein Pokalspiel zwischen Dresden und Hertha. Das war die beeindruckendste Auswärtskulisse, die ich je im Olympiastadion gesehen habe. Das war absurd. Und ich glaube, das werden sie sich jetzt nicht nehmen lassen nach der 2. Rückkehr. Aber so viel dazu. Ich denke, Dynamo haben wir somit auch besprochen. Es gibt bestimmt auch noch tausend andere Themen. Ist nun mal ein großer Trajitionsverein. Thomas, du hast kurz aufgeatmet. Wolltest du noch was einschieben?
Na, ich glaube tatsächlich, in Dresden, das ist so ein bisschen auch die Wette, die du jetzt eingehst, die du jetzt aufsteigend auch eingehen musst. Hast du ein bisschen so junge Spieler, dann hast du den ein oder anderen erfahren, damit da ferner, oder auch Kutschka. Und hoffst einfach, dass die jungen Spieler jetzt im Laufe der Saison so diesen Schritt machen. Und dann im Winter eben vielleicht noch ein, zwei Spieler dazuholen. Und ich glaube, dann kann das funktionieren. Also, weil ich glaube, das Wichtigste, was du brauchst, und ich finde, das hat Dresden, ist halt eine klare Idee, wie man Spiele beschreiten will. Die haben sie. Und wenn sie das noch schaffen, dass eben der eine oder andere Spieler den nächsten Entwicklungsschritt macht, oder vielleicht dazu noch im Winter die eine oder andere gute Ergänzung holen, dann kann das funktionieren. Ich glaube, von denen, die da unten jetzt gerade stehen und alle Probleme haben, traue ich Dresden das noch am ehesten zu, in der Konstellation, in der man ist, mit Trainern, mit Spielern, da eben auch am ehesten noch diesen Sprung nach oben zu schaffen. Eben auch, weil man da auch, wie du schon sagst, diese Wucht, die diese Stadion auch entwickeln kann, ich glaube schon, dass das ein Faktor sein kann. Und ich glaube, Dresden wird am Ende auch knapp, aber ich denke, die werden drin bleiben.
Sehr schön. Dann nehme ich die Moderationszügel in die Hand. Und führe aus dieser Sendung heraus, Anna, Thomas, das hat ganz, ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Vielen lieben Dank für eure Zeit, für eure Expertise. Das war nicht immer aufbauend, aber immer interessant. Und ansonsten, bevor ich euch hier aus der Sendung schicke, möchte ich natürlich noch erwähnen, es wird wieder Sendung geben. Oh, ich habe das falsche Audio abgespielt. Sehr gut. Passiert. Wir versuchen es nochmal. So, jetzt wird ein Schuh draus. Die Spenden ermöglichen ja auch, die ihr euch hier immer aus den Rippen leiert, dass es picke packe volle Rasenfunk-Wochen gibt. Am Sonntagabend gibt es die Bundesliga-Männer-Spieltag 6, Montagabend Bundesliga-Frauen-Spieltag 5. Bei den Männern gibt es dann die Länderspielpause. Dazu wird es auch beim Nationalteams-Feed wieder eine Sendung geben. rasenfunk.de ist gleich schon unterstützen. Schaut vorbei. Anna, Thomas, vielen lieben Dank und wir sind raus.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.